New Hampshire as an elementary school
teacher a general special education
teacher a reading and writing specialist
and an emotional behavioral
specialist I also served um uh I ran my
own business I ended up doing at pro
bono as a special education advocate for
parents who were um not having feeling
their children's needs needs were not
being met and this is what was the
Catalyst to this bill it my
experiences so what I did was everyone
should have a packet on I put one on
everyone's desk and I thought rather
than giving a speech I'm just going to
speak from the heart and try and get you
to understand my mindset in why I
brought this forward um and if you look
at the first part in Roman numeral 1 you
will see that the words I added are much
more
descriptive of the definition of what
literacy is and if we understand
literacy um components includes Reading
Writing math listening skills um and
everything that has to do with
communication one of the um challenges
that I found
was when we talk about phonics a lot of
people just think about decoding and
learning to read but phonics has two
components it also includes encoding
which means spelling that is not being
Tau in our New Hampshire schools anymore
they stopped teaching that in about
2017 when you look a little bit further
down I also included when we talk about
writing writing is not meaning that you
can actually form the words but that you
can actually write um in a coherent way
using appropriate grammar and
mechanics most schools stopped teaching
that around
2012 2015 somewhere in that area I
remember a language arts te teacher came
to me and said oh my God I'm not allowed
to teach parts of speech anymore well if
you can't teach parts of speech how do
you teach a child where to put the comma
how do you teach them to understand what
an introductory phrase is how do you get
them to actually build a coherent
constructive response which is a way of
writing that every child should know how
to do it's something I really in special
education that was where I put my focus
because if a child can write a
constructive response if they can start
with a general idea bring it down to
three main ideas the next three
paragraphs you you expand on those three
ideas and then you repeat your
introduction that's a five paragraph
essay that is what is required from
every child if they can do that they can
do anything in writing they can fill out
an application because they know how to
do a constructed response to tell people
what they're what they're
um uh what they're bringing to the table
you know and and it just it works in
every aspect of writing and every aspect
of where we have to stand up and talk
for
ourselves so this is why I added that I
want to move forward before going on to
Roman numeral 2 if you go to the next
page so as and I'll just back up one
minute as a special educator when I read
this an immediate flag went off in my
head because I'm like well this is
special education these are our
components of
literacy so if you go to the next and
this is what I'm talking about so as
part of my job as a special educator I
had to do the academic assessments with
children to determine whether or not
they met the criteria as a student with
a disability I use the y84 we also have
the Woodcock Johnson but they all cover
the same thing and if you look on the
back of page where it says wow You'll
see all the components that I would
check that I had to assess a child in
those components included
spelling they include essay composition
your five paragraph essay it's required
they expect you to see it in a
constructed response format if you look
further down you will see all of the
other um components the oral expression
um being able to speak coherently um all
of these things but we're not teaching
them anymore so now we're taking
children we're identifying them or not
we're taking them as a referral and
saying let's do an
evaluation well how am I how is that
evaluation even valid If the child never
learned the skills so now I'm going to
refer children because they never
learned they were never even given the
opportunity to learn a skill as opposed
to they can't learn it and so that's a
big problem and I saw that all along the
way the next um piece that I brought you
I'm not sure if anyone has ever seen
but a specific learning disability this
is the deliberation form I took off the
district's name there but all the
districts use the same this is a
Statewide
form so if you look through it and you
go to the second page of it you will see
does the child achieve adequately for
his age or meet the stage the state
approved grade level uh standards and
look what's there all of those same
things that's the Wyatt there's all
those components that's where I put does
the child know how to spell does the
child know how to uh write these are all
the components if they can't do
that they may well be eligible as a um
or qualify as a special education
student then they may need then we'll
determine if they need specialized
instruction
instruction the other page that I wanted
you to see and this is even more
concerning to me is then you go over to
uh the next page where it starts is
there a visual or a hearing well we
always rule that out first but then you
have to say if it's an intellectual
disability so if the child has under a
70 IQ then we're looking at a
developmentally disabled and so they
will not qual they don't qualify under a
specific learning disability but here I
worked with children with emotional
disturbance and I'm going to tell you
that in many cases children that are
just demonstrating uh behaviors in the
classroom are demonstrating those
behaviors because they can't read not
because they are emotionally disabled
instead it is because they are
frustrated this is a component of
Dyslexia the frustration the anxiety
imagine sitting in a classroom for six
hours a day while you're a teacher and
everyone else spoke in Latin or some
other foreign language that you can
understand it when they tell you it but
you can't read it you can't write it so
you act out because you don't want your
other classmates to see that you don't
know how to do these
skills
so then you go down a little bit further
and it's going to ask if there was any
um sorry it's on the next page I believe
but it's going to say does it have any
medical
findings well here's where your children
with other health impairment that's
where they're going to fall so if you
have these same children that you're
saying well they're ADH day well here's
another component of dyslexia it
presents as ADHD again the child becomes
antsy they become anxious they become
frustrated they start acting out they
can't sit still well of course because
they can't read and so I've seen more
children identified in as emotional
disabled or as an other health
impairment when in fact they were not
they could not read but they were being
misidentified so on my next page I gave
the latest it's a 2022 is how our
students in New Hampshire that have
disabilities how that spreads out in
each of the areas and you can see that
SD specific learning disability has
10,000 students as of
2022 so that's onethird of the total of
30,000 but I also pointed out the other
health impairment and you can see there
how many are there and they could be
there because they can't read not
because of a an actual Health impairment
that would be getting in their way of of
learning to read you could see in in
emotional disturbance as well how the
numbers go
up on the first part in the First Column
is where the grades are and this is
where I looked because I marked them out
for kindergarten 1 second third and
fourth grade and then you can say
typically um age 10 you're in fifth
grade in some schools that's a middle
school some it's still in an elementary
school but if you look at the numbers
look how they pop
to 1200 in specific learning
disabilities that they're being
identified in fifth grade there'll be
even more identified in sixth grade this
is Middle School what have these
children been doing for the last five or
six years they have not been accessing
the
curriculum they have been falling
further and further
behind this is extremely concerning to
me which is why I came to the conclusion
and I started telling people there seems
to be a rule of thumb and I'm going to
be honest it's not that there seems to
be there is an Unwritten rule of thumb
that until the child is two years behind
we will not
evaluate because we're waiting for some
other intervention to see if it will
work I can tell you that with all
certainty because for eight years I sat
in IEP meetings with children who were
being
tested and we would know unless they're
two years behind we're not moving
forward we have to first try all other
interventions that was eight years as a
teacher I also sat in IEP meetings four
years as a school
coordinator and I
knew we do not identify we do not move
ahead until those children are two years
behind then we will I will um evaluate
it's not written
anywhere I'm telling you that as an
Insider as to what I have
observed when I move
on so when I refer to the two years this
is where it's coming from I'm putting
the data together and these are all the
things I'm trying to again I'm trying to
give you my thought process over these
last several
years my next now this kind of is going
to now start going into to Roman numeral
2 and that's where I started talking
about the general education tier 2
intervention the
referrals um that if they're not meeting
grade expectations that they need to be
referred for intervention
immediately or at least when they're
demonstrating six months below their
that's half a year already teachers know
when the child is not staying up with
the rest of the classroom
I use the term in here on Roman numeral
to students who do not make meaningful
gains meaningful gains comes directly
out of the special education law and I
specifically use that term because we're
not looking for progress and I'm what
I'm seeing now is the general education
is starting to try and take pages from
the special education that's why we do
curriculum based assessment if you look
at how we assess special education
students now the general education is
being done the same way well the same
should hold true with what we're
expecting in intervention meaningful
gains means the Gap has to be getting
smaller it can't just mean progress it
can't just mean they did six last time
and they did seven this time it means
yes they did six this time but their
class has moved ahead further so we need
to see them doing eight nine we need to
see the Gap getting smaller
between where they are and where their
class is that's meaningful
gains that section there is the Catalyst
that understanding of my frustration
that intervention is only supposed to go
for 6 to eight weeks it is not supposed
to be going a year or two years they
should be implementing a good
scientifically based program in
intervention and we should be able to
see right away if the progress or the
meaningful gains are being made and if
that intervention is working and if it's
not working we need to try something
different and if it's still not working
that child must be referred to special
education for an evaluation we can't
wait we don't have time everyone knows
if a child is not reading at grade level
by grade
three the likelihood that they ever will
be at the same grade level as their as
their peers is very small and it's not
just about reading it's about all of the
curriculum they're not accessing
that is what made me write to our
education
commissioner and I specifically I was on
the phone with him for about a half hour
going over this what is going on with
this two-year rule of thumb that nobody
seems to want to acknowledge but is
happening in our state and he sent it
off to um Rebecca fet who I guess is in
charge of all of the special education
and and I highlighted because the
districts are left with the ability to
set guidelines for their reading
referrals and evaluations they vary from
District to
District well if if our guidelines vary
from District to District how are our
New Hampshire students getting fape how
are they getting a free appropriate
public education if they get one thing
in one district and another thing in
another District that is not Equitable
it's not
fair and it's it just undermines the
students's ability to move ahead as a
student so she referred to oh well Lori
must be referring to another section so
on your next page here's the other
section I'm referring to the IEP shall
um te I'm sorry the IEP team shall
within 15 days of the referral determine
this is the problem area determine
whether concerns raised by the referral
can be addressed using existing
pupil support services available to all
children that's tier
two but there's no there's no nothing in
there that says for how long so we have
children languishing and half the time
they're in that intervention the teacher
is doing Running Records she's not even
teaching in the one the children that
I've seen that are in intervention
they're not even using an actual program
they're just teaching what's in the
classroom slower or they're just making
the stuff up themselves there is nothing
that the child is getting so the child
stays there and languishes and Falls
further and farther
behind and I'm not saying that happens
everywhere some interventions are done
appropriately they're done quickly and
they work but in the cases where they're
not working we need to have a deadline
we need to say hey if after 6 months
that child is not making meaningful
gains they must before they fall two
years behind they must go to a special
education
referral my last piece of
evidence
stand behind everything I just said and
this comes from the United States
education
department and I highlighted the area
where it says that it is critical that
identification occur in a timely manner
two years is not timely six to eight
weeks I guess could be timely if it's
done correctly it certainly should not
be going longer than
that it goes on to say that RTI response
to intervention that's the tier 2
intervention cannot be used to delay a
referral or an
evaluation they could be moving forward
with an evaluation half the time even
more than half the time the first thing
we do is check the vision in the
screening so so while that child is in
the intervention we could still be in
the process of determining if we're
going to move forward with the
evaluation or have them in the in the
queue for getting evaluated to save some
time we have 60 or 90 days to get all of
that
done but this is what I feel is
happening I don't think that um changing
this would cost the district's money I
have heard some people say this is going
to be more expensive if we have to do
intervention and my response to that is
if you do the intervention sooner it
will cost you less because if you go
back to when children are being
identified in middle school if you look
at all of these numbers in order for
these children to be able to learn in
middle school they are going to have to
have a parot in their class they're
going to have to have some type of a par
professional helping them to access the
curriculum while they're in the
classroom room if we did this sooner if
we had this done by the time the child
is in third fourth grade and we know now
they're reading all of these extra
services that are required in the Middle
School would no longer be required
because that child is now accessing the
curriculum so in actuality it would cost
the districts Less in the wrong in the
long
run and that's where my experience has
told me and that is why I brought this
fot
thank
you thank you representative questions
uh from committee members uh
representative
lakus I'm wondering would this cause do
you think more kids identified as
special ed and do you think that
um do you think that it might lead to
over um categorizing them I do not think
that because my experience has been the
interventions that I gave in my special
education classroom were typically tier
interventions only very few amount of
children need that very intense reading
intervention um most good reading
programs if you look at the Wilson
Reading Program they have the General ad
the tier two and the tier three which
would be the um special ad that would be
a very intensive
program but these other tier 2 ones they
can be implemented right in the
classroom to be honest with you they
could be implemented with the whole
class they don't need to be brought out
to have these things um these skills
taught to them it could be integrated
right within the um the curriculum
that's being taught within the general
education classroom so I don't
think it would cause more special aded
what I would hope it would do is cause
when the children do go into
intervention that the interventions they
receive are going to be scientifically
based intervention programs that these
children are getting which is not what I
have seen when I've gone to District um
different districts as a special
education Advocate when I ask to see
what they're doing in intervention what
they show me is
appalling um so I would hope that it
would at least put something more if the
child does have to leave the classroom
for a tier 2 intervention that they
would be getting a legitimate tier 2
intervention thank you further questions
yes representative Hall Mr chair thank
you for taking my question and along the
same line as representative lakas do we
have a sense of how many kids percentage
wise go through the RTI and then are not
identified I don't have a specific
number but I can tell you my EXP
experience besides as a special um
education Advocate I can tell you my
experience with my own family members
have been that they have I knew that
there was a problem when they were in
kindergarten and they are still both in
second grade they were finally referred
to special education we still are
waiting because it will not be done
until June and I will tell you that I
will have them on grade level before
they get evaluated because I tutor them
using appropriate scientifically based
programs the will
program thank
you further questions representative
Woodcock good morning and thank you for
bringing this forward um I appreciate
the uh depth of material sincerely uh
having been uh sitting where you are uh
talking about this issue
uh is there
any way or any reason why the department
now I'm talking the DOE
uh that I mean rea fet the chair or the
department chair um coming out of doe
doesn't uh provide guidelines uh for I I
read about your twoe two-year lag piece
here from the commissioner and and sort
of just passing the ball while Local
Schools but it seemed to me that I I
agree with you first off okay but it
seemed to me that that if we wanted to
get all schools on board uh within the
State uh without a RSA just for
practical purpose the way it should be
um that there would be things coming out
of the commissioner's office have you
had any discussion with them have there
been any I've never seen any technical
advisories on this or early
interventions in terms of
recommendations uh perhaps uh doctor has
over there seen that but do you know of
any of this come out or why they haven't
come out I could tell you that when I
talked to the commissioner when I spoke
with him he was not aware that this was
happening and as you can see by the
response it's still just up to local
control I think the um commissioner and
the department is just going by this is
what the federal law is but just because
it's a federal law doesn't mean that we
as a state can't tighten it up and I I
just
um I think the O in my mind the only way
to do it is going to be by creating an
RSA and making sure that every district
is doing the same from District to
District especially given how transient
are Society is
today represent cell have follow up
thank you yes thank you just to follow
up on that I'm looking at the data your
documentation I understand the the
federal is two decades ago but the our
your response from the commissioner and
from uh Rebecca fad is 22 is two years
ago basically almost now have you seen
any movement from the commissioner or
from the Department of special education
to address this issue in few years I
have not I originally talked to him last
year this bill was going to come forward
last year and I pulled it because of
another similar bill that was coming and
so I pulled it and moving forward um as
far as the the 2011 bill or the letter
that is still in effect and I double
checked because where I found that
referenced and to be totally transparent
this did not come because I was educated
to be a teacher in New Hampshire or
because I was told this by a district um
I found in the
Connecticut um because my sister is also
a teacher down there and in their policy
handbook it's actually noted right in
their handbook and it is still today
noted so nothing in that this changes
this still valid ID prescription hasn't
changed but right I was just thinking
since you made the commissioner and the
department especially aware that we
thought maybe they might have done
something at two years thank you R
Corell if I could just I did the two
years ago but I have not seen any Chang
that's not a surprise thank you yes are
there any further uh questions from the
committee yes represent
representative go ahead Paul go
ahead I'm
new go ahead Paul thank you thank you Mr
chairman uh given uh the two broad
sections here uh that are you have
sought to either amend or to uh to add
new material with respect particular to
Roman numeral 2 and
um the uh length of your testimony let
me just say for the record since I'm new
to this committee how I uh how I miss
the uh the rules of the United States uh
House of Representatives where
representatives are given an allotted
time to ask a series of questions
because the the the breadth of the
material that you have spoken to today
prompts about 700 question questions
before you stopped otherwise it would
have been 8 or 900 so um I need to limit
myself to one question and I will do so
by asking you and and this is tough
because I I just got one and maybe a
followup let me ask you
um with the backdrop to my question
being that my grandson who's eight years
old comes to visit us he's a very bright
child and we're trying to read with this
child and this child has no idea how to
sound out a word he has never seen
before and therefore he hates reading
right and the testimony that was given
to me by our local school superintendent
to the effect that the school has appied
for a Federal grant to teach teachers
how to teach phonics so that they can
teach high school students remedial
reading before they
graduate how about that let me ask you
this question what percentage of the
students that you are seeing with
reading
difficulties would you say are having
difficulties because of the manner and
the the method in which they are being
taught
100% so that would be my answer um I
spoke to interestingly enough it was
another teacher from uh nashwa and she
was very excited to hear about my bill
because what it came down to is in
2014 is when fontas and panel
was shoved down our throats that's the
only way I can put it I excuse me for
being rude it was literally shoved down
our throats as teachers and we rebelled
and we said this will not work for half
of our students but it didn't matter the
decision was made the curriculum was
purchased and we had to go with it
luckily I'm special Ed so I could do my
own thing but the general education
teachers were forced to Now teach by
memory no more phonics no more grammar
no more spelling no more decoding
that was the downfall in 2014 the
science of reading has been around for
decades I was going to bring another
piece of evidence in 2010 I actually put
together a three pamphlet
folder folder whatever three pamphlet um
that I did in 2010 about the five
components of a good
reading um curriculum we were required
to do that as part of my graduate work
um and it was all the phonics phonemics
awareness fluency
comprehension that's nothing new they
call it the science of reading like it's
something new it's not new it has always
been here it's how most children learn
to read or I'll say at least 50% of them
learn to read now the difference is
children who can learn by the fontis and
panel method of
memorization they will only benefit even
more by learning the phonics and
learning to see the
um the patterns and why words are the
way written the way they're written or
spelled the way they're spelled but for
children who need that explicit
instruction who need to be told who need
to be shown and taught the patterns
they're never going to learn through the
memorization and that's the crime here
is that we went to a method that does
not work for all of our students all
students can learn through phonics but
only half can learn through memorization
and the worst thing is the fontis and
panel program tried to use some of the
um strategies that we would use as a
special educator to try and help
children while you're learning your
phonics well let's look at how the
sentence how does it fall let's see if
we can find some Clues but it wasn't
supposed to be the way you taught
reading that was just one little
component of trying to help students use
other methods
um the concern I have is is that the
majority of children with dyslexia are
average to above average
IQ so that means they are excellent at
finding compensating skills they're
excellent at flying under the radar
that's why so many of them are
identified in middle school it is the
worst thing to sit in a in a IEP meeting
with parents of a child in seventh or
eighth grade and tell them your child
has a reading disability and they're
like what now you're going to tell me
this now well because your child was
always able to memorize one syllable and
two syllable words but we're now more
sophisticated in the middle school and
going into high school we have multi-
syllabic words three and four syllables
and your child does not know how to
attack those words they can't sound them
out give a follow quick follow up thank
you Mr in your view what happened
in the runup to and including 2014 such
that this
new and improved quote unquote way of
learning or teaching reading was
implemented not as an additional tool
but the only tool a substitute for what
had worked for
Millennia that's a hard question to
answer without being Politically
Incorrect but I can't to lose nothing
since I'm retired um UNH those programs
came out of people who went to
un but you know you don't know why we
know why well publication let's sell
more book we know why on that yeah uh
further further questions from the
committee representative Balon thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm just going back to the bill
itself um on the uh on the part one it
says all school districts is there some
reason that you decided not to add
Charter
Schools I just we certainly could amend
it to say that but all the school
districts um I guess charter schools are
public schools within a district so it
would be covered as far as I can tell as
far as I know but that was not my
wording that was original wording of the
the way the bill stands today further
questions Yes again just going back to
the bill so there's really two two
segments that you're adding um one uh
provides a very specific definition of
what types of literacy and how it should
be taught um I also notice in the second
part is about the interventions
themselves so I'm wondering basically
this bill in one paragraphs just
mandates um evidence-based reading for
for all school districts um and taking
60 days taking effect 60 days after the
passage um there's no
if I look at the financial note I mean I
I I'm just thinking ahead um in order to
go about you're a teacher you know
anytime you change a particular type of
program there's a lot of professional
development around that needs to be done
a lot of support um and yet it can cost
districts an awful lot of money to
implement the program so I just would
like to have you speak to that thank
you the ran numeral one basically is a
definition of what New Hampshire would
consider as a literacy program the
components of a literacy program any
good reading program would have all of
these components and a math program
would have these components um in
them um as far as the professional
development I can tell you that we had
one day of professional development on
fontas and panel and then we were sent
off to go teach it as teachers we change
our curriculum all the time and we learn
we read the the teachers manual and we
follow it it's a scripted program or
that was um so that would be did I'm not
sure if I covered both your questions
fin question yeah the final one was just
the materials
cost um again most districts are now
moving away from the fontas nail program
and they're buying um programs or
purchasing programs that have more of
this phonics in it we just want to make
sure I would like to make sure that the
programs that they're purchasing that
they remember that uh phonics is both
encoding and decoding and writing
includes grammar and mechanics again
that's not something that you even need
much to if you're teaching reading all
you do is ask teach children to also
spell the words there's not a lot of um
components to add to
this other questions from the committee
yes represent Hall then represent
Woodcock thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you for taking the question did I
understand you earlier on that you said
schools do not teach five paragraph
writing and do not teach spelling now
and if if that's the case if if believe
that's the case did you check with all
school districts because I think that
that's I know my school district teaches
both of those I was told by someone in
the New Hampshire Department of
Education that in 2017 most of the
districts stopped teaching spelling I
can tell you that when I look at what my
grandchildren bring home and they're in
kindergarten to um fourth grade I am not
seeing spelling any spelling list coming
home and we do not work on spelling we
work on site wordss so you got that from
the doe then yes I did the um and the
other the grammar mechanics if you look
back into the Fontes and penel it kind
of or in the Luc Lucy Hawkins um
literacy which is another one that's
used for the writing it's really all
about getting children to write just
write just write just write but no one's
check checking to make sure that they're
writing coherently and so no I I do not
see that specifically being taught
Woodcock thank you just to follow um in
doly in your experience uh have you seen
any connection between either the
addition of the lack of early parent
reading with children as regards their
rating skill
development reading is a very
interesting um
because there's many components to it
there's visual spatial components um
children reversing
letters reading as a parent reading to a
child I can say I read to my children
every single night did that help them
learn to read no not necessarily because
that was all listening comprehension so
they have great listening comprehension
but whether or not they could read it is
those are two totally different types of
skills um and
honestly sometimes the whole idea of
reading by six is kind of a misnomer
because the brain has to make some
physiological changes before a child can
even read sometimes they are still
reversing putting their letters up and
down backwards different things they
have difficulty with but that's still
within the normal range if they're doing
that at 8 years old it's still normal um
in a normal range so it's just something
that you just continue to work with and
eventually um you hope that's going to
work its way out and if it doesn't then
may be a visual spatial um disability
going on there thank you are there any
other questions from the committee at
this time represent
Damon thank you Mr Excuse me thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so we have a written testimony
in front of us from a gentleman named
Tom newerk who identifies himself as a
professor Meritus at UNH and I won't go
into the details we we we're going to
have an individual by that name
testifying here great I would like to
hear representative Ball's response to
one of his remarks if I may so he
um speaks to the bill um requesting
evidence-based practices through grade
five um and then highlights
two um parts that he does not consider
to be evidence-based so I'm just
interested in your perspective or
response both on phonic
he he supports phonic in I think what we
have to do is stop saying what he he is
here he will spoke speak for he um okay
so just ask a question could you speak
to what degree of evidence-based
information is there for phonics in
grades three through
five so this would go all the way back
to Orton Gillingham that's he's the
grandfather of all phonics programs
every phonic program you will look at
will be based in Orton
Gillingham
um Wilson Barbara Wilson was a student
of Orton Gillingham she created another
program and then to say it's not
evidence-based would be kind of crazy
because we're going all the way
back decades and decades I mean I'd have
to go back and remember exactly when
Orton Gillingham was um when he did that
but it was I get I'm mixed up with Maria
montor
um but that's years and years of
evidence showing that these systems work
and have always worked and that's why
it's still today so prevalent to hear
Orton Gillingham the only reason I don't
necess I know I've been trained in Orton
Gillingham I've been trained in um
Wilson I've been trained in Linda mod
Bell I've been trained in her lips
program I've done the DOL program so I
know all these different programs but
they all basically Bally come back to
the same five components of phonics and
if we can't say that decades and decades
is evidencebased I don't know what more
evidence we would need thank you very
much other further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
very much for allowing me to present my
bill uh okay the next person up is uh
Tom
nuker
speak can you is your mic on push the
button yeah there you go I I always have
the trouble Schoolboard meetings I'm not
used to this system so um um I
appreciate this opportunity to talk on
um HB 1015 and I've limited my remarks
to about 3 minutes because I thought
that was kind of the the rule um my name
is Tom nuker I'm a professor emeritus
from the University of New Hampshire
I've also worked as an editor of books
for teachers that translate reading
comprehension Research into classroom
practice I have served for 11 years on
the oy River Cooperative School Board
though I speak here only for
myself I will speak in opposition to HB
1015 and I'll make just two
points um the bill mandates approaches
that are not I believe the bill mandates
approaches that are not themselves
evidence-based and this has been brought
up previously and I'll point to two the
bill requires explicit systematic
instruction in pheic awareness and
phonics through grade five and I think
this is highly problematic because if
you look at the national study research
panel on research study that came out in
around 2000 which is generally
considered the most comprehensive and
authoritative review of research the
evidence for phonic instruction in the
primary grades is strong as I think has
been pointed out the evidence Beyond
grade two is not strong it's that's not
an evidence-based practice according to
the National study will there be kids
students who might need that in remedial
situations absolutely but that's not
evidence-based the other point that's
not evidence-based is the instruction in
formal grammar for writing and of course
this depends on what you mean by grammar
and that's part the problem with this
bill is that a lot of these terms are
very nebulous and what does it mean to
teach grammar does it mean nouns and
verbs does it mean to to teach the cons
you know the formal construction of the
sentence but one of the facts in in um
writing research is it's been pretty
it's in clearly shown that taking time
to teach a lot of formal grammar to
teach formal structure of the sentence
does not translate into writing
instruction it of takes time away from
writing instruction because you're
teaching grammar instead of giving
students opportunity to write that goes
back to 1960 that's probably one of the
most authoritative conclusions in
writing research okay so I would argue
that paradoxically a bill that demands
evidence-based practice fails its own
standard that it fails its own standard
to be evidence-based at least in those
two areas and that should clearly be
changed if the spill goes
forward I want to speak more to section
two of the
bill section two of this bill creates an
unfunded Mandate of undetermined
proportion of undetermined
proportion it will fall most heavily on
poor school districts at least likely to
bear the
cost the bill will require a massive
number of referrals to level
two where students will get special
assistance perhaps from teachers but
teachers also have to teach the level
one but special assistance from AIDS par
professionals tutors and reading
Specialists since of referral comes when
the child is 6 months behind in any
competency it's almost certain that will
be there will be referral rates of 60 70
80% the data on learning recovery after
the pandemic shows many districts
average more than a year behind grade
level in
math support systems will be
overwhelmed I'm not saying this is not a
need I'm just saying support systems
will be overwhelmed you will have chaos
if you have that number of
referrals it would have been prudent to
do some sort of stress test to predict
how this bill would affect local
districts but in the methodology section
it is clear that no such attempt was
made there is the admission that this
bill may increase local expenditure by
an indeterminable amount by an
indeterminable amount in fiscal year
2025 and each year
thereafter in fact there is no way it
won't increase local expenditure by a
large
amount so three things are
clear in my
view the bill will place a financial
burden on local school districts to
provide level two support I can't see
that that won't happen from this
bill
two no efforts have been made to
determine the scale of this
burden and three the bill provides no
additional State funds to cover these
costs I'm going to say those again
okay the bill will place a financial
burden on local school districts to
provide level two support that seems to
be
incontrovertible two no efforts have
been made to determine the scale of this
burden and three the bill provides no
additional State funds to cover these
costs in other words it is an unfunded
Mandate of indeterminate
scale I submit to the committee that
either of these problems the requirement
of practices that are not evidence-based
and the unfunded mandated places on
school districts should make it
inexpedient to
legislate thank you thank you very much
much are questions from the committee
yes representative dry thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question can you explain to me what a
stress test to test this would be look
like I would think that you would try
to turned it
offed line okay um I would think you'd
want to go into a district and try to
use this metric of six
months and what so how many students
would that that require you to to
remediate to give some kind of level two
support then what kind of resources
would you have to give that kind of
support now if
if if for example like u in the the
recent New York Times They had they had
this big report on learning loss you
know and so you had urban districts that
you had urban districts are a year
behind you know where the average was a
year behind in math say say start with
third grade math just for the sake of
argument okay in third grade math if you
had 80% of your students in some Urban
District performing six months
behind what resources for remediation
would it take to remediate 80% cting
this bill
80% of those
students I think would be enormous you
know I mean so you could you could you
could you could look and see what it
would take to do that given the the kind
of um
um test scores you you have in these
districts and then then you could make
some kind of assessment of what the
impact would be the point I'm making is
for you to go forward with these kinds
of rubric these kinds of structures
without knowing what effect it will have
on districts you're you're kind of like
going into the unknown in in a serious
way I'm sorry go ahead yeah follow up
thank you um have you taken into
consideration also that in some cases
this might actually be a quick fix for
some students and that it's not once
they get into tier 2 they're there
forever true may may actually remediate
and and be
done I think I think that's a
possibility I'm just thinking the sheer
the sheer number of referrals to handle
that uh and you you can say you know
hopefully it will be you know you know a
quick fix but it might it might not some
KS might take more time I'm my point is
you should make some attempt to look at
the impact of what you're what you're
requiring of schools and and if you
don't which schools will be the most
affected by it okay it will be the
poorer
schools right because they will be the
ones that have the most students that
are performing so you're so you can say
that there's going to you know you can
maybe have like sixth grade teacher
remedial teachers com down you know I
appreciate the point was made previously
uh but it seems to be
inevitable and you know maybe I'm wrong
on this but it seems to be inevitable
that this will put the greatest
burden on the poorest schools who are at
least able to support that level of
remediation and
secondly there's no support to bring in
you know if if if my argument's right
that you would need more Personnel to do
this there's no money to do that so this
is like an unfunded mandate that will
fall
disproportionately on the schools least
able to handle it that's what I would
say yeah representative
leus I'm wondering what your suggestion
is then are we to just leave these kids
a year behind and then two years behind
and then 3 years behind because we don't
want
to stress the
school um my suggestion would be uh that
what's I mean I would totally agree with
the speaker before me I'm sorry I don't
should know your name Lor Lori ball uh
Lori says you that that I think that the
most important thing is to get early
intervention I think her argument that
when you leave leave kids in the system
for a long time that's uh you know they
become like what one of my graduate
students called lifers they become
lifers they you never get out so I think
what's needed is support
in you know maybe in in in conjunction
with some requirements for remediation
support for particularly for lower
income schools so they have tutorial
help so that they can provide this kind
of assistance
that's what I mean so I think to to to
just mandate this stuff without any kind
of support for poorer schools is it just
kind of it's It's kind of magical
thinking you know just it's kind of like
just do this and we're not going to give
you any money to do it and it's going to
work and and I so I would say that there
needs to be some effort to do that and I
think too that that part of the problem
as I see it in lower performing schools
is you have such turnover of teachers
and so there's it's it's like tied into
bigger Financial issues in terms of
teacher salary and and churn the kind of
churn that goes on in some lower income
schools so I think there's a lot of
things that I would do but I think one
thing I would do is to get to get
tutorial help one of the things that a
school like oyer river which is you know
we have tremendous advantages we've just
hired 15
tutors coming out of the pandemic and
that's really helped
us mediate learning law
and I think something like that needs to
go on in in other other school districts
but I think they don't have the
resources to do that uh I I don't think
you can wish this thing to happen
without any kind of you know support
Beyond just requirement for these these
these
deadlines ref Terry I go ahead and then
I want to ask ask a question after you
okay yeah I'll go first
um back in in
1970 mhm I was a fourth grade teacher
after I came back from Vietnam okay and
when I went and got my credentials to be
an elementary teacher was above and
beyond the bachelor's degree I presently
possessed but when I was trained I was
trained to be able to provide this type
of Remediation in my classroom we
usually had three or four different
reading levels which we were teaching
with in that classroom M with today the
average pupil teacher ratio in an
elementary school is down around 14 to1
12 to 14
to1 why is not
the Elementry classroom teacher able to
address these issues with the skills
they supposedly learn at the University
level I still think think I I think that
they they should be and I think that I
think certainly the teachers I've seen
are able to address a lot of those but I
think that there are situations where
they where they're going to need other
help or they're going to have to spend
more of their time with with the
teaching at the the the tier one so I'm
not saying that can't happen but I think
that to do what this bill requires would
take more Personnel in my view I don't
think you could just say te this this
teachers in situ they in can handle can
handle can handle this without that
extra support so I I'm not disagreeing
with you I'm just saying that that would
not be adequate to to handle this this
requirement I'll just follow it up I
then somebody's got to answer the
question for me excuse me that with a
ratio of 12:1
14:1 now we're saying we need to have a
ratio of 1 to six or one to
S and I don't know how we can sustain
that in public
education and with a remedial reading
teacher maybe on board in that school
that's support can be provided to the
classroom teacher for the classroom
teacher to impart to the child am I off
course or no I don't no no you're not of
course but I'm just my view is that to
do what this bill requires would take
more than that that's what I would say
Okay represent Terry Professor thank you
so uh um I I'd like to reference and
acknowledge that you have spoken to the
first sentence under that follows
numeral one the bill mandates approaches
that are not themselves evidence-based
and I've heard you speak to that thank
you so uh if we could go in the way back
machine back to Circuit 2014 at that
time did you believe that the uh then
new method of teaching reading was
evidence-based and if so would you the
new re the new method I'm sorry
2014 I'm new to the committee what what
do we call this Excuse me fontis pel yes
okay so
2014 langage are different different
than that
yeah so if I may um did did in 2014 or
Circle 2014 did you believe that there
was sufficient evidencebased uh material
to go forward with that methodology at
that time
and if so would you just speak to that
briefly how so I don't know that I had
an opinion on F and panel at that time
that's so
um I think that it's always been the
case that some that students need to
know sound symol correspondence I don't
think that that's ever been something I
didn't that's something I didn't believe
in I believe that foundas and pelis
that's been portrayed here is not
exactly accurate I think there is word
work and phonics in fonus and panel and
I just before I came here I looked at
the new book they have on literacy and
it has a section on on phonic so I I
don't think that's been exactly
represented correctly uh
I I I I think that I've always believed
that it's important for kids to become
Avid readers and for them
to have so things like classroom
libraries and self-chosen reading has
always been important so I've always
believed that so I would say I've always
believed that phonics and sound symbol
correspondence is important one of the
terrific things that's happened with
writing is often you get kids writing
earlier sounding Out words and that's a
terrific way to practice phonics so
early writing like four or five years
old and I've always thought that that
was really important so I've always
thought that
phonics was important important I think
that how much and who needs how much
there's some there needs to be some
differentiation there because you'll
have kids coming in like Scout and To
Kill a Mocking Bird who can you know
read right away and then you'll have
kids who need more intensive work so
that I think sometimes my concern with
some of these programs is you're going
to have like a one- siiz fits-all and
you're going to have kids going through
whole class instruction that don't need
it and there's an opportunity cost there
because then they're not doing other
things they should be doing so so I've
always believed it I've always believed
that it should be
differentiated um and I I think the
found and pel did have enough did they
have did have phonics and did have uh
strategies for for reading words and
sounding Out words was it enough I think
maybe there there should have been more
but but I think I've always felt that it
it should be it should be a part yeah so
going back to 214 I'd say
agreed but you're not sure on the the
question of of evidence-based
because is your question did I think
phonic not phonics did I think f
pel space at the time it was
introduced because that's the concern
you're raising here with respect to this
bill and effectively a return to phonic
as a primary means or way of of teaching
uh reading so I'm just wondering what
did you have a view as to whether there
was adequate evidence base in 2014 or
did you not remember or you weren't I
don't think I had an opinion I mean I
wasn't involved in in that so I was I
don't have an opinion on that great
thank you okay thanks are there further
questions from the committee yes
represent
luno thank you very much uh Mr chair and
thank you very much Professor new newerk
for uh being with us this morning
um I'm going to uh refer to um to the um
the methodology that was U that's listed
uh in the fiscal note that I think you
referenced a little bit earlier just
wondering if it comes as a surprise to
you that the um Department New Hampshire
Department of Education uh apparently
does not have any information on current
practices in place regarding um phonemic
awareness phonics fluency vocabulary
comprehension writing grammar and
mechanics speaking listening mathematic
reasoning that they don't have any
information
from any of the what do we
go60 plus um school districts across the
state he's reading exactly what's in the
the note I'm just wondering if that
comes as a surprise to you that that
that the Department of Education doesn't
have information on that it it does and
when I read that statement I
thought they're say I I I'd have to go
back and reread the statement my memory
of it is they they could not make an
assessment of the effect of this bill
because because they didn't have this
information so I'm so I'm doubly I'm
confused that they wouldn't have this
information but I think is that a reason
why you can't assess the impact of this
bill you know I'm not sure that I don't
follow the logic because it seems to me
that one of the
obligations and I've not been in your
seat you know so but it would seem to be
one of your jobs is to say what's the
what's the effect of this bill how is it
going to affect schools and how's it
going to affect schools
financially and my point that I've been
trying to make here
is you need to determine that I think
before you go forward with this bill so
maybe that's just repeating what I've
said before thank you thank you further
questions thank you very much thank you
I like to uh welcome Becky
Wilson
uh good morning members of the House
head committee and chairman lad thank
you for allowing me to speak today um
for those anyone who does not know Becky
Wilson I am the director of governmental
relations for the New Hampshire school
boards
Association uh we certainly appreciate
the focus on read instruction um and
provid providing uh increased
opportunities for students to be
proficient in Reading uh the focus of
this bill and several other bills that
have come before this committee uh we
realize it's a sensitive topic and a
place where there needs to be Focus
given uh across the state and I think
that has happened pretty significantly
over the past two sessions and continues
to be um however as many of you know uh
NH hsba is opposed to legislation that
would uh take away the ability of local
districts to make decisions on
curriculum uh and instruct at the local
level that matches their particular
Community needs uh we do have some
concerns with some of the terms in this
bill not being defined I think that's
been brought up before so I won't uh
harp on that in terms of measurable uh
evidence-based some of those other
things um I do want to just address as
well um a little bit about response to
intervention and some of the comments
that have been made about those
processes um RTI is meant to address
concerns when students are not meeting
whatever benchmarks and to vet out the
difference um excuse me between um
getting over a little cold so I
apologize uh meant to V out the
difference between students who need
help and students who may have a
substantial um need that could require
specially designed instruction under
special education eligibility um it's
not a question where sometimes
regardless of what's being taught in
school there may be a con concept or
skill where a student struggles with
that particular concept or skill it does
not necessarily mean that they are going
to meet eligibility for special
education uh response to intervention is
meant to provide exactly that a targeted
intervention to try to discern whether
or not the child just needs help with a
particular skill and once they learn it
as somebody I think mentioned previously
um that skill has been remediated that
deficit and the student can move forward
or whether the student really is
struggling with uh a concern that may
lead to special ed eligibility that is
what response to intervention is meant
to to address um to the sponsors point
it's not meant to be um this
longstanding system where students are
in that for an undetermined amount of
time uh however until 2004 uh idea
required that when a student was
referred to special education under
potentially needing uh special ed Force
specific learning
disability um districts were required to
use what was called the discrepancy
model which was you had to look at a
students overall ability score and the
scores that they achieved on specific
skills and there had to be between 20
and 25 Point discrepancy that was the
law you had to use that if you didn't
meet that discrepancy the child was not
eligible under uh specific learning
disability when idea was renewed or
redone in 200 for they allowed districts
to make a decision you could use the
discrepancy model uh many districts felt
that that was not really representative
of their students needs if you had a
particularly good score on a particular
day that you did the testing your kid
might not qualify and that might not be
representative of what their actual
needs were um so you could continue to
use the discrepancy model or you could
use an RTI model meaning you had
concerns about a student you would make
a referral um you would put put the
student into some sort of intervention
progress and process and see if they
made enough growth to make you feel like
they needed targeted intervention and
the team could decide at that point um
the reason the students doing better is
because of the intervention and they
need more of it so maybe they would be
eligible for special ed or it was enough
to close the gap that I think's been
mentioned several times um so many
districts use a combination of both of
those methods but you have to have one
of the two you can't just come up with
whatever process you want um I also
wanted to address the concern that I
think was brought up previously about
why numbers um of students with a
specific learning disability might
increase at age 10 um the reason for
that could be that there is a category
under special ed called developmental
disability which is uh when students are
very young and you're doing overall
ability testing on a six-year-old it's
very hard sometimes to feel as though
that really represents their full
potential um so you're allowed to
identify students to get special
education under what's called
developmental disability you have to say
what you suspect their overall
disability maybe down the road and then
by the time they turn 10 you have to
decide what other category they are
going to fall under or whether or not
they no longer are eligible so it's very
common that you might have some students
up through age nine that would be under
developmental disability that category
is not available after age 9 so then you
have to decide so they might fall under
specific learning disability and that
might be why you're seeing that increase
um lastly I want to speak to the
unfunded mandate piece of this bill um
just for people's overall knowledge um
some of these phonics based trainings
and specific trainings in terms of like
Orton Gillingham for example that's a
onetoone teaching situation to become a
level one Orton Gillingham uh teacher it
costs about $10,500 per person and takes
60 hours you have to keep that up over
time there's requirements that happen so
if you wanted to train a number of
teachers in your District to be Orton
Gillingham certified you could do that
but it's going to cost a pretty
significant amount of money never mind
you have to get someone to cover that
person's duties while the person is at
60 hours of training um the letters
training which is also a phonics based
approach which is being provided to some
people again it's $700 just for the
books and it's about 60 60 hours to
become level one certified it takes a
significant amount of time um same with
the Wilson program which is another
phonics based program so um there's
certainly lots of pieces of this bill we
understand the concern that students
need help you can't also supersede the
special ed process if someone makes a
referral the team has to address that
referral within 15 calendar days that's
that's it you have to dispose of the
referral but I want to be uh mindful of
the fact that just because a student is
referred does not necessarily mean that
the team is going to decide the student
needs further evaluation just because a
student is referred does not necessarily
mean the student is going to be found
eligible for special education so you
can respond to referrals but to the
previous um person's point in terms of
referral meetings require a certain
group of people to get together that is
required by federal and state law to
discuss the referral those people if you
have multiple referrals are not going to
be able to do the other parts of their
um jobs without getting other people to
cover them so you're going to need more
school psychologists more reading
Specialists more special ed teachers Etc
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you very much are there questions from
the committee yes represent petel thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um you mentioned how much it
cost to train somebody in Orton
Gillingham and I know that with the
Esser funds and I'm not exactly sure
with all of the details about what
they're allowed to use it for but um you
know there's a certain portion of it in
this phase three or third stage of the
Esser funds that they're allowed to use
it for learning loss and my District's
awarded $1.2 million they could train
120 teachers in Orton Gillingham would
that be an appropriate use of the Esser
funds uh thank you for the
question Orton Gillingham is a very
specific teaching methodology which as
you've heard has been around for a very
long time it is meant to be provided to
students who are substantially below
where they ought to be in a onetoone
situation for an extended period of
time to I think the previous speaker
point I'm not sure that pandemic
learning loss should qualify students as
being seen as having a disability per se
so whether or not you want to use those
kinds of strategies to try to mitigate
learning loss that would be a district
level decision but I'm not sure
providing every student a onetoone
reading period for 60 minutes a day
um and the is what a district would
choose to do with that those funds um
you also have to be very cautious that
whatever you provide through grant money
you can sustain once the grant is gone
um you have a maintenance of effort
that's required as part of your Grant
application you can't just give people
things as part of the Grant and then
when the grant Runs Out take them away
you have to be able to sustain those and
I'm not sure how a district would do
that further questions represent
Woodcock thank you chairman good morning
good morning um I'd like to refer just
uh to Professor nk's uh one of his
comments and and get your opinion he
indicated that he believes that this
will make a significant financial and
Staffing impact on schools less
uh funded uh and staffed at this point
that maybe uh taxing or almost he didn't
use the word uh unreliable but uh I'm
using that word that couldn't accomplish
that um would you agree with that
statement or you think this what's your
thinking on that uh thank you for the
question um over the past several
sessions there's been quite a few um
bills that have come out focused on
reading instruction um obligations of
districts in terms of providing reading
intervention reading assessment reading
instruction um because of the way that
legislation is written there has been a
very big impact on local districts in
terms of making sure that they have the
staff to provide the Assessments in the
timeline that's been identified um make
sure they have the staff that are
trained to understand the assessments
that they're given making sure they have
staff to be able to provide
interventions at the level that that
legislation has required making sure
that they can go to local public charter
schools uh because the local Lea is
responsible for that piece of it so
there are aspects of that that if you
were to kind of overlay that with this
particular proposed bill I think you
would see a very similar impact in that
you're requiring a certain type of
intervention on a certain timeline a
certain type of evaluation in terms of
special ed on an additional timeline on
top of the idea and on top of your state
guidelines that would force districts to
need to try to um staff in a way that
would be able to meet that legislation
and I think for some of your um less um
your more resource poor districts they
already have a difficult time Staffing
some of these things that are already
required so I think if you're looking at
trying to provide additional special ed
staff in a district that already is
resource poor trying to find more people
to come in to do that um would be
difficult and I also think that when you
look at the full system in those
districts um they may have a fairly
robust um RTI process the problem is
that you're changing the criteria that
the district has already sort of dis put
into practice on how they're working
people through those systems so the
impact on that would be I think again
undeterminable but if you wanted to
provide you know more specific phonics
based instruction you're looking at at
least you know 10 to 15,000 per teacher
um just to get the people you already
have sort of schooled up in that
particular way thank you
yes um thank based on your Association
your uh your school Association and and
around the state are there
uh sufficient number a reading
specialists at this point in time let's
say this enacted and to come in in Fall
for September are there enough reading
Specialists even available in the state
of Hampshire uh thank you for the
question I don't know the number of
people at the department that are
certified under that particular license
I'm sure the department could get you
that information the question is how
districts are using their reading
Specialists whether they're using them
more as a consultant model that I think
someone had mentioned earlier where the
reading specialist is training teachers
to provide the interventions or whether
the reading Specialists are required to
provide them themselves if that makes
sense thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you represent
leus I'm trying to figure out why you
said Orton Gillingham needs to be
oneon-one and only for special needs and
so maybe it's not Orton Gillingham but I
I remember in the early 60s when I was
in elementary school they they came out
with this whole new phonics whatever and
the teachers were given the materials
and they followed the materials and the
instructions and the materials and we
did it as a whole class the teacher
taught it as a whole class it wasn't it
was not 101 it was not any of that and
it was not go spend huge amounts of
money per teacher to them be able to
take one-on-one and all of that it was
just here's the materials the materials
explained how to use it boom they used
it boom we all learned
phonics explain to me why where you're
coming up with these I don't know
oneon-one and special ad and all this
other stuff when we're talking when it
doesn't even say Bon Gillingham is
talking about all of these things which
is what I learned and it was new thank
you for the question the question is
where did I come up with the criteria
for and
Gillingham well or or why it's going to
cost or why it's going to cost all of
this money for each teacher and why you
expect them to be one-on-one and only
special ed in all of that other kind of
stuff doesn't it make sense that if it's
a method that works that we would use it
with all students instead of one on one
and only to specialed students and does
it have to be Orton Gillingham if that
takes requires individual instruction or
why we wouldn't just use the whole
basic like we did when I was a kid and
the teachers were given the materials
and like um they were talking about when
they came out with the
new stuff the teachers were giving
materials and they followed it right and
that's what happened to my teacher when
they came out here's the
materials do it thank thank you for the
questions I think I would do my best to
try to answer all of those thank
you um in terms of or Gillingham and how
oron Gillingham specifically is provided
that is the way that that program is
designed and developed and so if you
want to become certified in that or your
District wants you to become certified
that is what you are agreeing to do I
can't speak to why Orton Gillingham
decided that that was the way to go but
that is that is the way that it works um
there are many many districts in the
state of New Hampshire who use a Wilson
beas whole group approach called
foundations I'm sure you've heard of it
if any of you still have contact with
kids in schools that are in the
elementary young grades you probably
have heard of Foundations there's a
whole again a curriculum that goes with
that again your teachers need to be
trained in that you need to buy the
curriculum for every single teacher they
all need their own manuals they need
their own supplies and there's
differentiation within that program that
you must provide as a general Leed
teacher you have a lot of people that
you are bringing into the system uh who
are on alternative pathway programs to
become certified who have never gone to
teacher prep so to address somebody's
comment earlier about how come people
just don't know what to do if you've
never been part of a teacher prep
program you're not coming in with any
understanding of brain-based learning
how people learn how to read you're
learning all of that as you go while
you're also learning how to implement
the foundations program for example um
and there's a lot of training that goes
with implementing foundations with
Fidelity it's very easy to read things
out of a manual but that's not
necessarily what um general education
people will tell you is implementing a
program with Fidelity uh and then if you
don't Implement these programs with
Fidelity what happens is you get a
skewed number of students who are
referred for intervention because it's
based off of uh inconsistent
implementation of a program across a
school so you will end up with some
classrooms who are getting multitudes of
referrals to special ed or intervention
and some that aren't getting any because
people are implementing what they think
the program is supposed to be but not
necessarily understanding why they need
to implement it in a particular way so
these programs all come with their own
criteria um there is money attached to
all of that whether or not the district
has to come up with those funds to train
their entire staff but foundations for
example is a wh School approach you
train all of your teachers and everybody
that is involved with it from K to three
typically um how a district funds that
and manages that is um up to the
district because they're determining
that that is the instruction or
curriculum that they want to use it's
not a mandate that's being handed down
thank you very much are there any other
questions thank you thank you you um
Jerry
FW welcome thank you Mr chairman thank
you members of the committee I'll keep
my remarks very brief Mr chair as I
recognize the facial angst of you
running behind schedule for your
hearings so you got it I'm hearing you
um but uh first of all we appreciate
very much the sponsor's concern and
share with the sponsor the importance of
literacy for all kids at early ages so
that they don't become behavioral
problems they don't become dropouts and
they don't become issues later on um and
potentially criminals down the road uh
so reading instruction and literacy is
incredibly important um I'm not going to
be labor points that were made by
Professor newerk or I can't be nearly as
eloquent as Miss Wilson in her in her
testimony in pointing out the the
various factors I would like to raise a
couple of concerns and I believe some of
them most of them have been brought up
um but I won't be label them um I
believe representative balbon uh uh
brought up the fact that this only
applies to school districts and why not
charter schools and and why not and I
think it does have to be specific that
it applies to Charter Schools uh and uh
also um you know other entities that
receive public funds perhaps to add
grade levels of
remediation um require Staffing and they
require resources and I think about our
large cities and what they would spend
uh and in uh trying to support and where
does that instruction take place some of
our buildings are cramped for space and
where do you where do you pull the small
groups of kids uh out to offer that
required tier 2 instruction or uh you
know the potential increase in
developing educ
individual education plans IEPs through
the special education process when we're
already experiencing shortages of staff
for par Educators service providers
teachers um there are there's a human
component here of providing that level
of instruction and I believe another
representative raised the question about
you know the role of parents in helping
to prepare children for reading and
supporting you know the Bedtime reading
stuff and and those things um
level two in special education cost
money classroom teachers working with
parents are best suited to make the best
educational choices for their kids in
their local level and that happens and
I'm here to tell you unless you spent
and and I even though I'm not sitting in
one of those chairs I listen to every
hearing that this committee has and and
the perspective that you all bring to
the table every one of us in this room
everyone here everyone there everyone in
this building has a museum of school in
their mind right what their school
experience was I can remember sixth
grade like it was yesterday because it
scared the hell out of me but that that
said
um we all think we know what schools
look like these days and I'm here to
tell you we
don't we don't don't spend an hour in a
classroom don't spend a day in your
local school go spend a week when the
committee can ever stop meeting go spend
a week in your local school in the
second third or fourth grade classroom
and see what happens observe the
instruction see the attention that kids
get see the support that they get with
par Educators if they can find par
Educators see the support that they get
through special education systems
currently in place we don't need another
law we don't need another prescription
for education
this is well-intended and absolutely
Wilson Reading systems are great Orton
Gillingham is great Becky talked about
the costs involved with those the time
element of professional development the
training required and it's not oneand
done it may be a million dollars you
might be able to spend that Esra money
for for the initial training but what
happens when theer money goes away and
it's going to go away soon so then what
happens to maintain that training to
maintain that opportunity for all kids
coming down the pike not just the kids
in school right now not just trying to
recover that and so I think that's
important we nhsaa sees this as a forced
local taxation by the state as a
superintendent I'm thinking about
developing my budget for the you know
next Tuesday next Tuesday many school
districts adopt their budgets for next
year okay this law takes into effect 60
days after passage that can't happen
Okay districts have their budgets in
place even two years out it's going to
this law would impact local taxation
because it requires staff it requires
intensive training and support for kids
not just one or two hours a day all the
days of the year in in these classrooms
and uh so with that I'll stop because I
told you I would thank you very much
questions representative Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for being
here and taking my question independent
of the clearly very concerning costs of
this proposed
legislation do you see any need for what
it proposes to do as contrasted with
what is currently happening in schools
to teach these competencies thank you
for the question representative Damon
what I do see is the
inequity of How It's applied and all due
respect to Professor
um new Kirk and and the Oyster River
experience is probably looking pretty
different today than the experience in
Newport where they can't hire power
professionals they can't find the
people and so the concern is how do the
kids in Newport get the same experience
as the kids in
deram or Amherst or Bedford and oh by
the way they do spelling tests because I
have grandchildren in the Bedford
schools and they're studying for their
spelling tests so spelling happens
spelling tests
happen thank you further
questions thank you very much and with
that I'm going to close this
hearing and getting ready to move into
the next one for today which is
1654 relative to review of Education
Freedom accounts service
providers
[Music]
do you have any cards on
it this pardon me
I
okay okay we're on 1654 if there's
anybody that has a desire to speak on
this when you please get a pink card to
us we're sitting here with none and
we'll get yours represent luno upon
completing uh welcome representative
luno would you please go forward with
1654 thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Dave luno representing the people of
Bo and Hopkinton and folks all across
the uh the lovely Granite State and um
I'm here to introduce this morning uh
House Bill
1654 which is relative to review of
Education Freedom account service
providers so um just to make sure we're
uh we're we're clear on the um on the um
um the the terminology here Education
Service Providers are defined in the
education Freedom account statute uh in
194f uh as being the um the the the term
used for for every third-party
organization that provides things from
services such as um instructional
Services private schooling uh but also
materials that may be books or
curriculum and things like that they're
all Educational Service Providers and uh
the bill before us this morning um only
applies to education service providers
that are um that are part of the um the
education Freedom account program and um
and in the um in the statute that exists
today I'm just going to pull it up real
quick I
can under um 194f colon 6
um the uh the the present statute um uh
puts uh puts a few requirements on um
Education Service Providers and one of
those requirements is to uh comply with
all state and federal anti
discrimination laws so that's um in the
statute right now
194 F colon 6 Rome
two
um paragraph
C so what uh what the bill before us
today does is it
modifies uh that statute 194 F 6 by
inserting another paragraph Roman three
and it's real short it's only a few
sentences um couple sentences long and
um and what what what Roman 3
adds is essentially two two things one
that Education Service Providers have to
develop and Implement an
anti-discrimination
policy that's outlined under RSA 193
colon 3 9 so that's a state
anti-discrimination law it's a law that
the education service providers already
have to comply with but now they have to
put together a policy on how they will
uh Implement develop and Implement an
anti-discrimination their own
anti-discrimination policy consistent
with that and the second thing that uh
that the bill does in this new Roman 3
is um require the State Board of
Education
to conduct an annual review of the
Education Service uh providers for
continued compliance with their policy
and um and so uh I don't think it's a
heavy
ask
uh in
the it's not a heavy ask there there's I
mean this is about
anti-discrimination and there's a lot of
people when it comes to
anti-discrimination
that talk the talk but what this bill
does is it walks the
walk and that's the intent of um House
Bill 1654 thank you very much are there
any questions represent
leus if I'm a book
seller and I sell whatever the parent
ask
for and how am I a going to discriminate
and B going to come up with a
policy that's going to say I'm not going
to discriminate if all I'm doing is
selling whatever book a parent asks for
and see how is the Department of
Education going to determine whether or
not I followed some policy about un
anti-discrimination when all I'm doing
is selling whatever book a parent ask
for sure thank you very much for the
question so um so this is a this is a
great example of how businesses
businesses that we do business with
every day whether they're Gibson's
bookstore right here on um Main Street
and Conquer I think the oldest
continuing operating business in uh in
the city of conquered and um um and it
would require if if Gibson's bookstore
was to be approved as an education
service provider that they would have to
have a non-discrimination policy that
would guide the development and
implementation of a coordinated plan so
now I'm actually reading from
19339 to prevent assess the presence of
intervene in and respond to incidents of
discrimination on the basis of age sex
gender identity sexual orientation race
color marital status familial status
excuse me disability religion national
origin or any other classes protected
under 354a um and so so as far as a
bookstore is concerned that could have
to do with hiring practices it could
have to do with discriminating um
against having
discriminating um actions against uh
against potential customers uh or
potential or contractors they do
business with um uh bookstores do uh do
business with uh with Distributors so um
so making sure that there's that there's
no discrimination on that so just as it
would apply to just about any business
uh whether it's a bookstore a restaurant
or anything like that
further questions representative
cordelli um thank you uh thank you
representative luno um I'm just
wondering about um religious
organizations um let's say um a Catholic
school did not want to hire a a a
teacher who was uh possibly an atheist
and um uh had uh uh opinions contrary to
um the teachings um of that school um
would they uh possibly be in violation
of your proposed um statute so so what
they would be in what what what they
would be measured against is the policy
that they develop and and if their
policy uh says that that we're not going
to hire somebody that believes in
something totally different than than
what we believe um that that may may
may be something that uh that that
allows that to work out um uh for them
so it's that's that's why this
isn't I mean keep in mind again all of
the education service providers have to
comply with state and federal
anti-discrimination laws what this bill
is doing is saying they have to develop
their own policy based on based on um uh
19339 with the paragraph I just read in
terms of how they Implement um that
policy so obviously you know I'm not an
expert in this area uh but but if
there's a policy that passes Muster that
allows them to not hire uh certain
people who don't have the um the the
background or understanding or skills or
something like that then clearly you
know people don't get hired for um for
those types of reasons so so uh possibly
that's that's a way that that could be
address yes so then um in terms of their
following um state law right and
anti-discrimination laws as as you
pointed out um that would also apply to
uh RSA 354 a colon 18 which is an
exemption from the statutes for
religious organizations so that uh
statute would apply to a a religious uh
School of any type correct yeah I mean
if if if that's the um uh any other
classes protected under
354a so so I'm reading from 19339 so
this all this all follows so if you say
that's what follows What flows from that
um uh ref I have one question here I'll
go back to your reference to Gibson yeah
which I'm sure you're very familiar with
through your family correct um um if in
fact gives and then contracts with
another
organization to provide books or
materials and then the the EFA program
or whatever it may be is you buying
those books from Gibson's but the
corporation or the business that's
providing it to Gibsons do they also
have to have a such a policy that's
being recommended right now yeah I don't
thank you for very much for the question
I don't really read this as as as
implying or requiring a a second level
indirection on um on that this this is
specifically to education service
providers who have been um I don't know
what the term is in 194 approved by the
um by the uh the the scholarship
organization so so if um if if if if a
um if an education Service Pro provider
subsequently contracts out I I I'm I'm
not reading this as having you know
infinite NE Terry so uh thank you so you
you have um indicated uh that uh and
you're referencing uh in existing law so
why would there need in your view to be
a policy what are the implications for
not having a policy so the implications
for not having a policy are um are are
probably
at least twofold one of them is
education service providers differ in a
lot of different ways some of them are
providing instructional Services some of
them are excuse me providing materials
such as books and um and they're they're
the way they Implement
anti-discrimination um policies
consistent with state and federal law
may be dependent upon what type of
business they they are so so that's the
that's the first thing the second thing
um is that it actually gives the State
Board of Education the ability to
annually review that business against
their compliance with with their policy
uh on that and um and you know and and
I'm not I'm not suggesting that every
education service provider would have an
identical policy uh internal policy with
regards to anti-discrimination because
like I said I think it would be
dependent upon the type of business they
are and the business practices that they
um um you know that they that they have
so um so you know this is all about a
let's if we're going to talk the talk
let's walk the walk and this puts puts
some teeth behind uh anti-discrimination
when it comes to the um the education
Freedom account
program further questions represent dry
thank you thank you for taking my
question how does this mesh with 194 F7
the independence of Education service
providers where there nothing in this
chapter is deemed to limit the
independence autonomy of the providers
um they're given maximum freedom to
provide for this nothing ISS construed
to expand the regulatory authority of
the state and it goes on and on I mean
they're given Pro protection here from
having to make any alterations to their
Creeds or practices in order to accept
EFA
funds yeah and and uh thank you and and
and I think they would just have to um
um you know call that out in their
anti-discrimination policy and obviously
there's there's a lot to
194f um 194f is also referencing um uh
sorry
19339 one of the state's
anti-discrimination policies and if they
want to lean on a um a policy that is by
definition discriminatory in terms of
hiring or doing business or Contracting
or something like that then um then then
if they want to uh you know lean on what
you just uh read then then they're then
they've got statutory backing on it but
uh but again this goes to talk the talk
walk the walk and and if they're going
to if they're going to have
discrimination uh in their hiring
practices or other business practices
that say so and um and they can lean on
the statute you just
called represent leus you have a
followup go ahead to when you say their
policy you're talking about the policy
of the Scholastic organization the the
education service provider because
that's this like I said this bill
requires two things for the education
service provider to develop their own
policy and for the State Board of
Education to annually review for
compliance against
that repr
leus do we have the ability in New
Hampshire as legislators to pass laws
that affect people in other
states if if we're approving them to do
business I mean we I I believe the um U
there are New Hampshire Contracting laws
Contracting requirements that are
attached to every contract that the
executive Council passes and whether
those contractors are based in New
Hampshire or based outside of New
Hampshire and if contractors don't
comply with with those Provisions then
they don't do business with New
Hampshire yeah so yes so follow up yes
so we would be able to ask that of
Amazon and Amazon would have to come up
with a policy and then our doe would be
able to track Amazon and see whether or
not they followed their policy um that's
a great question I I would
be so I don't know specific in the in in
the in the example of Amazon but given
how how large that company is and and
how much reach they have globally I'd be
surprised if Amazon does not have an
anti-discrimination policy of their own
and we'd be able to make sure they
follow follow up yes please would we be
able to make sure would the doe have the
ability to make sure that Amazon
followed their policy yeah I'm I'm I'm
I'm sure they'd have an ability to do
that represent
Woodcock yes thank you chairman Le thank
you I'm I'm a pretty simple guy I'm
finding this very confusing I uh in
respect
that everyone in the business field for
the most part now who does hiring and
does other
operations knows what the Discrimination
piece is and they follow it so all
you're asking am I right here all you're
asking them to do is put it in writing
and give it to us so we can make sure
you're following it is that what is that
what this is yeah that's what I thought
okay thank you I got a question here um
why did you in your language here put
the task for the annual review on the
State Board of Education rather than on
the scholarship
organization um that's a good question
um you know so so I think it it just
provides a level of of oversight and
accountability that is connected to um
uh directly back to the
state okay represent McDonald thank you
Mr chair representative do you know the
number or could you provide an estimate
of the current service providers that
may not be in
compliance I I don't have any specific
information of any service providers
that that are not in compliance of the
current statute um I don't know how many
of those do not have their own internal
not anti-discrimination policies and may
I have a follow-up
question if 60 days after this bill's
passage it is determined that a service
provider is not in compliance what
happens to the students that have
already purchased say textbooks from
that service complier would they have to
refund the EFA program through class
wallet digital
wallet a texbook they already paid for
and is that expense on the family is it
retroactive how does that work yeah so I
don't I don't I don't know how that uh
would work I think that would bear out
in in the rulemaking authority that has
afforded the State Board of Education
under
541a uh which is referenced in 194 4f um
and um and you know I would I would
certainly expect that um that any of the
education service providers uh that uh
that are already approved by the in the
EFA program that don't have their own
internal uh anti-discrimination policy
on the books would um would be able to
um to craft something relatively quickly
and uh and and get something done um uh
consistent with this chapter yeah
last question from represent cordelli uh
thank you back on schedule well no we
have we're not there yet we trying to
get there um I just wanted to follow up
on uh chairman lad's uh previous
question and um the State Board of
Education um uh ensuring comp uh
continues of compliance and you said
with the policies that they have put in
place but it also says with all state
and federal
anti-discrimination law so I'm just
wondering how the State Board is going
to make sure that they are in compliance
with state and federal
law yeah well we're already requiring
that of the education service providers
in
194f so so again this is this is this is
the teeth um uh on that so so um again
not an expert in this area but I think
that would have to bear out under
rulemaking okay so I'm not going to
allow any more questions for repres for
those in the committee we will be
executing this bill and I'm sure you can
pose a question at that time he he'll be
here I'm sure
yeah so thank you very much great thank
and David
Trumble
good morning Mr chairman and committee
members get my papers together
sorry I need my
glasses this is not a
Monday
apologize my name is David Trumble I'm
from the town of wear and I support this
bill for a couple reasons first of all
schools teach by their example RSA 19339
makes it clear that civil rights apply
to our public schools and they must be
free of discrimination against all the
listed classes there's no place in
education for discrimin ation or
Prejudice the New Hampshire Constitution
says the purpose of education is the
preservation of a free government and
the Supreme Court defined it as
furthering the political and social
viability of the state schools don't
just teach lessons they teach by their
example and by prohibiting
discrimination Public Schools provide
equality education to every child and
further teach all of our children the
important lesson that everybody is
worthy of respect and should be treated
equally in the eyes of the law second if
we fund
schools or education service providers
that permit discrimination this works
against the Constitutional purpose of
discrimination not only will we be
denying that appropriate education to
all children but we would indeed be
teaching students that discrimination
and Prejudice are acceptable the US
Supreme Court had the case of Norwood
versus Harrison back in 1973 on a 90
decision they held that a state cannot
provide Aid to a private school that
discriminates based on race and the the
ing was that discriminatory treatment
exerts a pervasive influence on the
entire educational process it doesn't
just affect that child it affects
everybody in fact it affects our whole
community so if schools have policies
that uphold prejudice and discrimination
then the state is within its legal
rights to refuse to fund
them a few specific areas one lgbtq
children most Americans 70% incomparable
percentages of most major religious
denominations except for white
evangelicals support same-sex marriage
and do not find homosexuality to
conflict with their religion there are
many religious schools that find
discrimination against lgbtq people to
be toxic and hurtful and believe there's
no place for such attitudes and beliefs
their educational policies would comply
with this statute and would comply with
the state civil rights laws I think that
all schools who receive EFA funds should
have policies where all lgbtq students
are welcome and no student should be
treated as sinful due to their sexual
Orient ation specialed students number
two they make up 20% of the children in
our public schools and they are all
welcome there and they all have a legal
right to a free and appropriate
education they are vastly
underrepresented in EFA schools at
between 6 and 7% I believe that an EFA
school should include the word
disability in their statement on
non-discrimination guarantee that
students will not lose their legal
rights under the idea accept all
students with disabilities provide
appropriate education to all those
students and adopt discipline policies
that would keep students in school not
on a fast track to expulsion and lastly
English language Learners I believe that
EFA schools should adopt the same
policies as public schools to provide
Educational Services to all students
including those who need education in
additional English I'll just finish up
with a quote from professors Kevin
wellner from the University of Colorado
School of Education and law and Preston
Green from the University of Connecticut
they wrote in private school vouchers
legal challenges and civil rights
protections whether publicly governed or
privately operated schools must still
prepare students for life for jobs and
for participation in our democracy they
must serve all students not just the
easiest or least expensive to educate
they must abide by core ideas of
fairness protecting children against
bigotry and discrimination and certainly
not actively subjugate subjugating
children to these harms and they must
meet basic standards of accountability
and performance thank you very much
thank you very much other there
questions from the committee representa
Terry yes thank you
um I kind of got stuck at the point
where you identified a group called
White
evangelicals okay I was read uh so I was
wondering um where you would Place black
evangelicals Asian
evangelicals and uh uh and Latino
evangelicals would they be with the
white evangelicals or with the 70%
majority thank you for the question
representative um I was with only 3
minutes I don't have time didn't have
time to give you the breakdown I was
citing from an NBC news report from 2020
it's in my written testimony and it
breaks down and it says most I'll just
read you the simple paragraph it answers
your question directly most major
religious denominations back marriage
equality including white Mainline
Protestants 79% Hispanic Roman Catholics
78% religious non-christians 72%
Hispanic Protestants 68% white Catholics
67% black Protestants 57% and other
Christian denominations 56% thank you
you're welcome sir further questions
from the committee represent leus just a
followup on that one what about
Muslims uh I don't have that part of
this I'm sorry there was a long article
I only cut and pasted that paragraph to
keep it short because my understanding
is that Muslims do not agree with um
homosexual marriage I am not an expert
on that and I'm afraid I cannot answer
that question thank you thank you very
much are there further questions thank
you I'd like to welcome Mary
wilky that's a different
Bill good morning good morning Mr chair
and members of the committee thank you
for hearing from me I'm Mary wilky live
in Conquer New Hampshire and I'm a
retired public school teacher um I don't
want to repeat some of what I've heard
so I'll I gather that we're trying to
move along quickly and uh I came L late
but um I just wanted to read uh
something quickly to you and then a
couple of statements um the whenever I
look at section 354a the
anti-discrimination statute I'm kind of
inspired by the preamble to it and one
part of it says the general court hereby
finds and declares that practices of
discrimination against any of its
inhabitants because of and list all the
different categories um are a matter of
State concern that such discrimination
not only threatens the rights and proper
privileges of its inhab abant but
menaces the institutions and Foundation
of a free Democratic State and threatens
the peace order health safety and
general welfare of the state and its
inhabitants um the EFA program has is in
a sense you could describe it as a kind
of parallel system of Education offered
to uh a large percentage of our
population and funded at least in part
by The Who are funded at least in part
by the public to go to whatever system
or opportunities they choose and it's uh
as I've followed it it seems it's based
on the premise that money raised via
taxation for uh for Education should
quote follow the child and it's my
belief that if the public money is going
to follow the child then so should the
rights that they would have if they had
stayed in public school and I that's
just um I don't think I'm going to go
much further than that I just feel
anything we can do to ensure that
students wherever they're trying to get
an education are not having the door
closed on them because of their
disability their lgbtq status whatever
the status might be we should be uh we
should be strengthening those
protections because public money is
involved I don't think any taxpayer
should have to pay taxes that go to a
school that their own child would not be
allowed in because of their
race color religion um disability lgbtq
status Etc it seems to me once we've
injected public money into these private
places then public rights should also
follow thank you thank you very much
Mary are there questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you and with
that
no he's not no
no I'm not going to allow
it FR to come up
yeah
okay good morning
morning I'm Kate Baker deur is this on
if it's red yeah okay good executive
director of children's scholarship fund
I wasn't going to testify but um I do
need to share just some concerns that I
have um there are no schools in New
Hampshire that are discriminating
against children of those
groups that um the last person who
testified
discussed existing laws already prevent
discrimination and so the concerns that
I have are um the discussion that you're
having around this policy that schools
will need to put into
place the children that are coming to us
at Children's scholarship fund in these
types of situations that are
experiencing discrimination are coming
to us looking for an alternative the
schools that they are coming to us from
already have this policy in place does
that make sense so this 193
39 policy exists in the public schools
or charter schools that they're coming
to us from and so saying that putting
this constraint on the place that
they're going
to how does that solve a challenge right
so families are coming to us because
they might experience discrimination
racism and they're looking for a safe
alternative and so to say that this
solves something having them create a
policy that already exists in the places
they're experiencing that that bullying
or discrimination or racism just seems
backwards to me in addition um the State
Board of Ed is not the Human Rights
Commission if someone experiences those
types of scenarios they would go to the
Human Rights Commission to find reconcil
iation and help to say that the State
Board of Ed should be able to even
assess a a discrimination or
non-discrimination policy I I don't
think the State Board of Ed even has
that skill set to be able to look at say
Amazon's policy and decide if it meets
the criteria to me that would be
something that belongs in the Human
Rights
Commission and then again I just want to
reiterate that the existing organization
and entities that exist in New Hampshire
all fall into our
non-discrimination policies that exist
and laws that exist and it's the
opposite entities are not discriminating
against children in different groups
they're helping them to be able to solve
some of those existing problems so
thanks for hearing me out thank you very
much are there questions representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you take
my question you're
welcome so you've clearly stated two or
three times that the existing Education
Service Providers although you didn't
use that term but I understand that's
what you
mean are not discriminating so could you
please explain why is it a policy for
why is it a problem for them to have a
policy that says they don't discriminate
yes they they do already have policies
that that say they don't discriminate
under state law and so I I just don't
think this makes sense to put the State
Board of Ed in a position where they're
monitoring those non-discrimination
policies when they don't have the skill
set to do that it's the Human Rights
Commission who would enforce any type of
non-discrimination and and again I'm
finding that kids are coming to us
because they're experiencing this in
places that already have this policy and
so for me it's just a question of
logic
yes are you saying that the education
service providers all already have this
policy so businesses and and schools
usually have posted on their website a
non-discrimination policy that already
exists
yes person Hall thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question so
problem are you as a followup so are you
saying that education service providers
all Education Service Providers uh have
policies have policies I I'm guessing
I'm gu I'm guessing that it's not
something that we monitor but if you
think about any entity business school
otherwise like I know I can think of
schools where you go to their website
and right at the bottom it says
non-discrimination BL policy blah blah
blah I mean that's a normal procedure
for anyone in my opinion the the
challenge with this bill is again
putting the onus on the State Board of
Ed to try and have any like I I I
understand the sponsor was calling that
teeth but I think that's the opposite of
teeth right to me the people who are
civil rights experts would be the people
who if a family was experiencing this
type of situation right they would go to
the Civil Rights experts at the Human
Rights Commission
to get some sort of reconciliation to me
you're putting like a speed bump in
their way like what if a family
experienced discrimination and then went
to the State Board of Ed when they
should be going to the Human Rights
Commission I mean to me you're almost
creating a mechanism where you would
confuse someone who was actually
experiencing a situation where they were
being
disenfranchised right the families that
come to us are looking for a situation
that's not the situation where they're
being dis franchise currently and this
already exists there and so if you have
an existing public school or a charter
school this policy already exists there
and and it's not having it may not be
having the effect that that the sponsor
wants it to because families are still
coming to us and saying I'm experiencing
my child is experiencing discrimination
or racism or bullying because I'm an
lgbtq kid and I need to go somewhere
else and so then to take it the idea and
then put it over here when it's already
seems to be and again it's my
circumstantial information right I
didn't go collect data about how many
reports there are of this I just know
that for example lgbtq kids are the most
bullied kids in any school and to say
that this is working there I think it
would be an overstatement when those are
the families that are coming to us to do
something else why would we do the same
thing over there when they already have
the Human Rights Commission that could
enforce any
any discrimination that they experienced
and
so thank you no I'm I'd rather move on
we have some other questions we're also
getting into the time of the next one so
if there's other people haven't asked
questions to this point on this uh yes
I'd like to have them speak
representative
pel I just wanted to
clarify um briefly so if I'm correct
what I'm hearing you say is that
children are leaving in you children and
parents and families who um take
advantage of the education Freedom
accounts are leaving possibly leaving an
institution where they do not feel
included so that they can go to an
educational opportunity where they will
feel included is that what you were
trying to say does that sum it up well
it's it's different than just inclusion
I mean sometimes the families or
children are experiencing even violence
to come to us and it is a very small
group right I can't make broad
statements because again there are
families who remember take the education
Freedom account money and pay a public
school for classes and courses so I'm
not I can't make a broad statement I'm
just telling you that a small group of
families come to us because their child
is experiencing what they say is racism
or bullying or you know specifically
being targeted because they're an lgbtq
kid and they're coming to us to go do
something else else and they're coming
from a place where this policy that
we're discussing and this bill already
exists to go somewhere else so I'm just
to me that's not a it's not a solution
to that challenge when that's why
families a small group of families are
coming to us to go to somewhere else
that that's that was my thank are there
any other qu ref Woodcock thank you hi
representative um I just want I
understand I understand the whole School
versus school I got all that yeah and
there is a there already is a protocol
for the Human Rights Commission I
understand that yeah but if I understand
from one of the having looked at some of
the print outs from the uh organization
yeah there are multiple providers yeah
that they deal with the organization for
a host of things for youngsters fine all
it forgetting the kids in the school
park we know they already have
anti-discrimination policies right as
the most of the receiving schools they
have them as well so yes but there are
other provided that this bill will
attack provide their requirement to to
take what they have for an in essence
working policy and put it in writing and
send it to the State Board of Education
it's not suggesting the State Board of
Education is is going to be the in Lee
of the the human rights board not at all
this is just saying if you if you do
these things just show us the policy
that's all it is so I don't want to
confuse the the big issue of LBG or
antidiscrimination in schools and school
there's a host of other providers that
that should require to keep disc that's
that's all yeah to your point I think it
would be challenging to implement
because there are sometimes a provider
that doesn't know they're a provider so
if a family is choosing for example
right now we're trying to on board all
the community colleges in New Hampshire
so that the families can pay them
directly but a family could get
reimbursed if they paid the community
college and then gave us the receipt and
so there might be entities that don't
necessarily know that a family has used
their um service or bought something
there and so I think that's kind of A
Wrinkle in this where there'd be a group
of providers that don't necessarily I
remember in the oversight committee um
there's a representative on the
oversight committee who has a school and
a family had been reimbursed for tuition
they had paid at that school and the uh
representative didn't didn't know that
it was it was news to them and so that
part of that this I think is
unenforceable but the there thank you Mr
chairman yeah uh are there any more
questions of thank you thank you very
much uh like call forward Barett
Christina wow um bar Christina thank you
chairman lad bar Christina executive
director New Hampshire school boards
Association we are not taking a position
on this bill I want want that to be
clear um the anti-discrimination
provisions relative to vouchers I
addressed three or four years ago with
House Bill 20 whenever whenever that
that bill was I just want to clarify a
couple things RSA
357-a col 27 opportunity for public
education without discrimination is a
civil right the protected classes age
sex gender identity sexual orientation
race color marital status family status
disability religion or national
origin a little a Catholic school I
don't want to say which one this is
their anti-discrimination policy race
color National and ethnic origin nothing
about special education nothing about
transgender
status another school um that I found
again I'm not going to name which one
their anti-discrimination policy race
color National and ethnic origin nothing
about transgender status nothing about
disability that's all I have to say I'll
take any questions represent cardelli
thank you well maybe you could look up
uh 354 a Col 18 which is the religious
exemption happy to do that
sir okay nothing in this chapter ex
nothing contained in this chapter shall
be construed to Bar any religious or
denominational institutional
organization or any organizational
organization operated for charitable
purposes yeah that nhba doesn't dispute
that certain organizations private
entities are allowed to discriminate or
have their own admissions policies
that's been my
testimony consistently throughout
throughout all all the voucher bills I'm
not saying a Catholic school has to
accept transgender kids or a Muslim
school has to accept non-muslims that is
not the point of nhba testimony again
I'm not taking a position on this bill I
just want to clarify
that private schools expecting accepting
EFA money are allowed to discriminate
and if whether they choose to or not
that's fine that's not my prerogative
but they're allowed to do so and they're
their their anti-discrimination policies
on their websites say this here's
another one the school reserves the
right within its sole discretion to
refuse admission of an applicant to disc
or of an applicant to disc discontinue
enrollment of a student probably without
due process mind you so you know we we
don't need to go down that rabbit hole
either but I just want to clarify that
private schools accepting EFA money are
allowed to discriminate and nhba is not
taking making a value statement about
that but L there be any confusion as to
what some of the previous testimony I
just wanted to clarify that for the
committee thank you very much other
questions represent thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question in
reading of the bill I as I read it maybe
you can tell me if you read it the same
way um it's just saying that they have
to publish and have a policy correct
thank for the question representative I
don't have the bill in front of me I
trust you're reading it
accurately thank you representative pet
now thank you I'm just confused you um
referred to the voucher program and as
far as I know we have an education
Freedom account program can you point to
the RSA where the voucher program exists
yeah thank you it's RSA
194f I believe EFA and Esa they're all
types of vouchers sort of me like if I
were at White Park and I said look at
that malard and somebody said that's a
mailer that's a duck I I I think it's a
distinguishment without a difference
representative further questions thank
you very much represent
Horgan yes I'm back so I'm represent Tim
I continue to be represent Timothy
horens just like it was yesterday from
straford County District 10
the town of Durham I think I mean I this
is one of those bills when you look at
I'm surprised it was necessary because I
just figured that would already be the
case that you wouldn't want um you
wouldn't want to be providing taxpayer
Monies to an organization that uh that
discriminates although we did have the
bill yesterday which uh dealt with
certain issues in the Human Rights
Commission so so I think this is very
common sense Bill if they're accepting
these taxpayer dollars they should be um
not just will but eager to um eager to U
go along with the
anti-discrimination laws and also um
this doesn't directly affect the
scholarship organization um the uh but
uh but they they they also should be
bound by the
anti-discrimination Discrimination laws
and so and of course we do also have the
situation where we have a entitlement
program which is growing pretty rapidly
and there's lots of Bill to expand it
and we've turned it over to we turned
over the administration of this program
to a fairly small organization that's
not clear who they're accountable to and
you know so compare that for example to
the cash benefits like tanif or Aid to
the uh disabled or food stamps which
have a very well first of all they have
anti-discrimination policies in place
for that program but they have a very
like robust uh governance there's like a
whole floor of people over on Pleasant
Street who Minister those programs and
also the Department of a there's a
federal program of private contractors
so we've turned over a program that's
certainly as complicated as food stamps
or cash benefits and um we're we' turned
it over to just this um small
organization whose headquarters in Mr
chairman talking about t for food stamps
here we're we're talking about an EFA
program yes talking about there there's
ISS please stay on topic okay efas so
I'll there are numerous issues with the
governance and program and one of them
is the anti-discrimination policies so
there should be one and it should be
reviewed on a regular basis and we
should not be giving taxpayer money to
organizations that discriminate and that
seems pretty simple to me and um
I'm thank you are is there any questions
I see thank you very much and this
closes our our hearing for
1654 I think he he
supporting
no just I'm noting here wor no no put
for what you put sign it up for that's I
put
okay po the
bill good catch there
yeah
moving forward with the next bill which
we have on the docket for this morning
it's
hb650 this is a bill relative to the
approval of alternative programs for
granting credit leading to graduation
and the prime sponsor of the bill is
represent luno welcome represent luno
thank you thank you very much Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
Dave luno representing the people of
hopkington and Bo and all across our uh
what would normally this time the year
be a snow covered Granite State so um um
appreciate the um the opportunity this
morning to introduce House Bill uh
1650 um I'm glad we were able to spend
so much time on the proceeding bill
because a lot of this material will will
is directly relevant to 1650 and while
the uh proceeding bill was was directed
specifically to the education Freedom
account program and education service
providers 6 1950 is directed to what is
commonly referred to as the learn
everywhere program and um and um um
alternative programs that are approved
by the state board for um uh for
granting credit leading to graduation uh
under uh what's commonly known as the
learn everywhere program so the um uh
the the learn everywhere program was
actually established in um
in 193
e2a um Roman
5 and U and under current law uh there's
not much to uh to that statute other
than the state board can approve
alternative programs leading to um uh
credit leading to graduation um the um
uh the only provision that's uh that's
currently under there is that the State
Board of Education can adopt rules to
manage that program under
541a so what uh what 1650 does is uh
goes a little bit beyond that and um and
actually you know establishes um more of
a hard deck for uh for these alternative
programs uh which are subject to
approval by the state board and unlike
the previous bill which um which which
which where where the statute
194f uh does reference compliance with
uh with state and federal
anti-discrimination laws there's no such
requirement in statute for programs
approved um to be um to be run as part
of the what's known as the learn
everywhere program so um so this
um this bill High School 1650 does three
things uh it requires that uh that
thirdparty programs uh to be approved by
the State Board of Education under this
program um comply with um with Federal
and um and and state non-is
anti-discrimination programs and have
policies in place that are required of
school districts and charter schools
which would have to accept credits for
leading to graduation from these
programs uh um have policies in
place set forth under RSA
19339 so that's the that's the chapter
in the law that we were just talking
about that um that uh uh requires the
the development of policy that guides
the development and implementation of a
coordinated PR plan to prevent assess
the presence of intervene in and respond
to
incidences of discrimination on the
basis of all the protected classes that
um uh that we talked about before so so
uh so it it requires that keep in mind
the learn everywhere what it's known as
the learn everywhere program um is to is
to it is basically something that works
hand and glove with local um uh public
schools to earn credit leading to
graduation so this is a public school
program so that's the first thing it
does it is it it establishes that hard
deck for an anti-discrimination policy
the second thing it does and this is on
sort of lines um uh 8 through 20 of the
bill so one two and three um uh the
second thing it does is um is require
requires that an ad hoc committee
evaluate the application for programs
that are applying to be part of the
learn everywhere uh program uh much of
this in fact
it may be that all of this is currently
in rules uh that govern the program
except for the sh part and why is that
important because if it doesn't actually
require an ad hoc committee to evaluate
the application then in some cases it
doesn't happen and in some cases it
didn't happen uh for example when when a
program was uh was being um uh put forth
for for approval uh during the middle of
last summer when um when when a lot of
lot of um you know teaching faculty are
on vacation or maybe working you know in
in summer camps or in summer jobs uh in
other parts of the country or in New
Hampshire so so um so it requires that
an ad hoc committee can be convened to
evaluate the the application like I said
I took the um these these Provisions
from existing rules and then the third
thing it does and again this is very
similar to what we were just talking
about um requires an annual review to be
conducted by the State Board of
Education um of these um uh educational
programs approved under the learn
everywhere program for continued
compliance with their with state federal
anti-discrimination laws including the
policy that uh that's that they're
required to have under um under this um
uh provision so uh with that I I hope
people see a lot of common elements
except you know with with the uh with
the education Freedom account program
there was the talk the talk and we put
in the walk the walk this does both of
these things because under current
Provisions Uh current statutory
Provisions it doesn't require um uh
compliance with anti-discrimination laws
so this is let's talk the talk and let's
walk the walk thank you thank you very
much are there questions from the
committee representative cordelli thank
you um just wondering if
um especially um B1 that you added here
would that uh apply to uh locally
approved ELO
programs uh no th this um this applies
specifically under programs that are um
that are approved by the State Board of
Education I believe a locally uh
approved program would certainly have to
comply with um with all the policies
that the public school district has in
place which include policies on under um
under RSA 19339 so that provision would
already be in place yes thank you but
that that requirement for the ELO
programs approved locally is nowhere in
statute that they would comply with
19339 well they would have to because
they're they're they're essentially
being being part of the public school
offering the public school has to be
compliant with uh with
19339 further questions from the
committee represent
leus I'm wondering how this would apply
to say
a I don't know an air for an
air um training for kids to be able to
go
and get a p you know Learn to Fly
because disabilities are included in
that and I can certainly think of a
number of disabilities that would
disqualify a kid from learning how to
fly and would that mean that then no
kids would get to do that because they
couldn't accept all kids yeah so thank
you for the uh thank you for the
question um
uh in the case of a flight school they
would have to have an
anti-discrimination policy that um that
would have to be compliant with
19339 and certainly many disabilities uh
uh would be accommodations could be made
so that uh so that uh somebody with a
disability could uh could take flight
lessons and receive a a pilot's license
in the case that um that that they would
not be able to eventually receive a
pilot pilot's license perhaps um they
could go through some of the other parts
of Flight Training which incl include
Ground School and uh and that may be uh
be a possibility but uh but there's
certainly um so many other uh of the
protected class classes that uh that we
would not want the um uh a flight school
that's that's approved under the the
what's known as the learn everywhere
program to be discriminating against um
uh lgbtq Plus or on any of those other
um uh protected classes further
questions you have another question yes
I'm but I'm
wondering yes there are those others but
this law doesn't say accept it says all
of them and so if a flight school can't
accommodate all of them does that mean
nobody
can uh no I I I disagree with that uh
with that premise I believe that that
the flight school could certainly uh
adopt uh adapt a program to uh to meet
just about um you know all the needs of
uh of all the needs of people that are
interested in um in experiencing that
program
thank you further questions represent
dry thank you and thank you for taking
my question I I'm going to ask the
question we asked yesterday in a similar
bill um are there examples right now of
this being violated I don't have any
examples thank you further questions
from the committee see thank you very
much great thank you very much uh
commissioner
edbl good morning again
good
morning good morning for the record my
name is Frank edbl I'm the commissioner
of education for the Department of
Education uh members of the education
committee thank you for your service to
the state and to your constituents
speaking on behalf of the Department of
Education we appreciate your efforts to
advance opportunities for all children
in the state of New Hampshire so that
each one might realize a bright future
I generally try to avoid hearings such
as this but appreciate the invitation to
come and speak with
you my experience is that when I do show
up it can be a bit of a distraction to
your good work and that you are
otherwise doing and I would not want
that to be the case
today reading the language of hb650 I
could not help um but assume that this
bill uh that some people may refer to
this bill as one of those a solution in
search of a problem a less generous
reading of the statutory language might
be that it is a deliberate attempt to
limit student opportunity but not just
any student rather the language limits
the opportunity of otherwise
disadvantage students here in the state
of New
Hampshire and I can't imagine that
anyone would want this as an outcome of
the proposed
law the statute seems to be targeted and
I the um Prime sponsor has indicated at
a uh Department program called learn
everywhere for those of you unfamiliar
with the program um you know the program
is affectionately called that because
whether we understand that or not
children are learning everywhere and
they are learning all the time uh
learning is not limited to the hours of
7:30 to 2:30 in a specific location that
is simply contrary to human nature for
your reference this particular program
has been recognized lauded and written
about Al by the right likes of Rick Hess
among others and for those of you who
are unfamiliar with Rick Hess he is a
nationally recognized voice for public
education learn everywhere program
allows students to earn credit for
learning that takes place everywhere and
I sometimes tell the story of one of my
own sons who attended Berkeley in his
first semester at Berkeley uh the
college allowed him to test out of 18
college credits recognizing that he had
already mastered the requisite content
here in New Hampshire we too Aspire for
this type of a competency based Learning
System that acknowledges student
learning section one of the statutory
language is targeted in RSA
19339 which is an
anti-discrimination prevention policy
that is required by our Public
Schools if the sponsor of this bill is
concerned with discriminator
discriminatory practices of learn
everywhere program we at the department
have had no such
complaints the sponsor should understand
that any learn everywhere program is of
course and I've heard a lot of
misstatements about this up here in both
the last hearing as well um is subject
to the New Hampshire and federal
anti-discrimination statutes including
RSA
354a any out of school program would
also of course be subject to
anti-discrimination provision
of their state as well as the federal
statutes so all of these businesses all
of these entities are are bound by law
in order to be have and follow the
anti-discrimination
practices it was interesting because the
sponsor indicated that other outside of
school learning programs would have this
policy in place when in fact that's not
the
case um if the objective is a sponsor is
to provide added protections to students
and we do want to protect our students
who are engaged in learning
opportunities outside of the Traditional
School environment and thus subjecting
them to
19339 it would be necessary to cast a
far wider net than this bill
contemplates students in New Hampshire
participate in learning opportunities
with for-profit and non for-profit
entities in the state as well as around
the
world whether those are learn everywhere
programs Extended Learning opportunities
or work as learning programs s students
are learning in more than 800
organizations across the state and
around the globe these outside of school
learning experiences include and I have
a relatively long list that I will uh
share some of the names on here with but
main Drilling and Blasting FedEx over in
londondary the Manchester Animal Shelter
Barefoot Medical Spa Cheshire Medical
Center Handover Police Department YMC of
conquered L3 uh Welsh floro carbon easy
concrete novel iron alphabets Learning
Center All State Insurance White
Mountain lumber yard madok paper
mill uh Albany service station Aroma
Joe's if you get your coffee there you
might be served up by a New Hampshire
student learning some stuff uh du lingo
uh is even one of our Pro providers Ira
Toyota of Manchester Lake sopy plumbing
and heating as you can see we have got a
large number of organizations that
provide learning opportunities for
students what the sponsor might not
understand is that these are an
essential part of the education
landscape here in New Hampshire I might
add that many states are actually
jealous of the extent of the many
opportunities that New Hampshire
students are afforded it would not be
realistic to assume that FedEx or
Dartmouth Hitchcock as an example are
going to subject themselves to RSA 193
339 and adapt the policy that we require
for our Public Schools they simply won't
do it and they are already subject to
RSA 354a anti-discrimination Provisions
right these are not entities that are
exempt from that so the effect of this
bill will simply be to limit unique
Hands-On educational opportunities for
our students and in particular our
disadvantaged students the research is
clear when underperforming students
students are afforded opportunities to
learn outside of the traditional
classroom and the classroom
instructional environment they do better
and they are more engaged other
provisions of the statute create policy
much of which is already embedded in the
rule approved by learn everywhere
program which has been pointed out and
in fact the proposed statutory language
itself references the program rules
which is I would say is not a good
practice in terms of you don't want to
reference rules in statute because then
that makes the rules the statute um um
there is no logical reason to implement
this policy unless the goal is to limit
opportunity and harm these students and
I am certain that that could not be the
case thank you for allowing me to meet
with you and address this today and I
can answer any questions people might
thank you very much commissioner are
there any questions from the
committee representa Tanner thank you
thank you for taking my question
actually I have two questions if I can
have a followup my first one is um that
354a applies to employment whereas the
non-discrimination statutes under uh the
education laws apply to education so
even though like groni or some of these
other wonderful places that you've
mentioned uh do subscribe to the
antidiscrimination laws can can't they
still refuse to allow a student to come
into their group uh who wishes to be you
know to do a um coffee and uh is has a
disability that they may have to do uh
some modification for yeah so thank you
for that question so in fact the statute
that's referenced here has nothing to do
with anti-discrimination it has to do
with an anti-discrimination policy
that's what the 19339 is dealing with
all of these other entities are subject
to the
354a and the federal uh Title 9 title 7
anti-discrimination Provisions so for
example you know any of these businesses
if someone walks in you can't
discriminate them against them based on
their race their disability or any of
those things so all of those laws apply
to all of these entities there is not
something uh new or unique to the
schools the schools as well are subject
to anti-discrimination Provisions just
like these other entities are and the
only difference is in this particular
statute you require them to have a
specific
policy further questions from the
committee I think she said she had two
but I didn't the other the other one was
recently the learn everywhere program
dropped their a background check uh uh
provision and I'm just wondering why
that happened yeah so that was adjusted
in the rules to make the learn
everywhere programs more accessible for
the local schools um because as you know
learn everywhere is basically kind of a
state Extended Learning opportunity um
and some of the schools have actually
taken up the learn everywhere programs
and adopted them into their schools as
Extended Learning opportunities and none
of the schools learn everywhere programs
had that type of a background check so
it was limiting the school's
ability further questions represent Hall
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so you said the
effect of this bill would have a uh
would limit the uh unique Hands-On
experiences for particularly
disadvantaged kids can you give a
specific example of that sure I'd love
to tell you a story about a kid over in
Hinsdale I was visiting the school one
day
and um this particular student uh was
characterized to me as not a
particularly good student at at risk of
dropping out of school um I had the
opportunity to meet with them uh during
a lunch in
program and uh I was talking to the kid
I was like you know what's up like they
tell me you're not doing that well in
school that you're at risk of dropping
out like what's going on and it was just
like I just don't like school it seems
boring it's just they it's it's coercive
they're telling what to do all the time
and I just want to learn I just want to
do my thing so this particular student
had an outside of school learning
experience at a contractor working with
a contractor um the particular school
has a block schedule so this student was
allowed to leave school during the third
block and there was a building
construction project near the school and
they would go and for 90 minutes every
day they would go and they would work on
this particular construction project
later in the day I was continuing my
tour of the school and I went into an AP
Physics class an advanced placement
physics class and this student was in
there I was a little shocked truthfully
um and I said you know I I was like what
are you doing in here this is AP Physics
this is not supposed to be for you know
kids who are at risk of dropping out
while you're here and I asked the
teacher how's he doing he says he's
doing great I said well what's going on
and he said a couple of things he said
first of all here in physics what I'm
learning are the very things I'm
learning on the construction site like I
go out and I can see kind of what a
candle lever is how the roof is pitched
and how the weight load is you know in
the construction and how that all works
and he said so it makes the learning
that I have much more engaging and then
the second thing he said is and I get to
leave at the third period so I get to
move around right I get I feel like I
get I have freedom right I get to go and
I get to move and then I come back to
school and I feel like I can sit down I
can concentrate for this fourth period
this fourth uh Block in his schedule so
that is an example of a student who um
is taking advantage of these outside of
school learning
opportunities and and by doing so they
are then bringing that success back into
their education so that they can be
successful yes so follow up um so what
would this bill how would this bill
prevent that from happening because it's
unlikely that that Builder is going to
install a policy relative to
anti-discrimination that Builder is
already Bound by the anti-discrimination
laws so that Builder if I went to them
and says not only do you have to comply
with the anti discrimination laws not
only do you have to among these other
800 businesses and organizations open up
your building and and your business and
create opportunities for students but
we're also going to require you to
implement the same policy that the
school district has when in fact there's
no value associated with it you heard
testimony up here before that even in
the schools that require this policy we
still have discrimination taking place
so I guess what I would tell you is that
it will limit those opportunities
because they are going to be more
resistant from these organizations
participating and allowing students to
participate in their programming thank
you further questions from the committee
yes represent Balon thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
I'm a new representative so I don't know
about the program um but could you
please explain to me what is the
difference between the learn everywhere
program and uh the opportunities
presented in that program versus the um
Extended learn learning opportunities
program um monitored by the school
districts so they are very similar
programs in the sense that an Extended
Learning opportunity is a learn
everywhere program that is generated out
of the local school district and the
student is participating a learn
everywhere program is an Extended
Learning opportunity that is generated
out of the state and afforded to all the
students across the state um part of the
purpose there is really not all
districts have the ability to establish
and set up and support students in those
learn in those Extended Learning
opportunities and so learn everywhere
programs essentially bring Extended
Learning opportunities to all school
students all all children in our schools
across the state yes um and a followup
um credits are awarded for these
opportunities I know in local school
districts they determine how those
credits are awarded how does the state
determine how those credits are awarded
yes so just to be clear so with the
students in the learn everywhere program
aren't awarded credits they're awarded
credit certificates which are redeemable
for credit at the local high school so
it kind of has that same effect and the
way that those credits are awarded is
that the programs are assessing whether
or not the students have met
competencies and uh So based upon the
student meeting competencies the way
that our uh State rule regulatory schema
works if a student has demonstrated
Mastery of competencies they're required
to be wed
credit so I'll give you an example of
that works sure well give me I'll give
you an example of how that works and so
in our first robotics program so first
robotics is a uh a learn everywhere
program and so you have the mentors of
the first robotics team who are signing
off that a student has met uh
engineering competencies or that they've
signed off that they've met coding
competencies or they signed off that
they've met uh business competencies um
and so that is how we assess those
competencies and it's different for each
learn everywhere
program um so it is actually
the the organization through learn
enware determines the certificate or the
recommended credits and then this but
again and then the receiving High School
is required to accept those credits as
listed if they've met the competencies
that's correct so the organization is
signing off that the student has met the
competencies and then they get a
certificate that they've met those
competencies which under existing law if
a student has met competencies they're
required to receive
credit got it thank you thank you
represent Tanner um thank you and thank
you for taking my question so we're
talking about competencies this just
kind of you know um in a school the
competencies and the rubrics and
everything are generated within the
local school district um are there
Statewide competencies I mean how does
um somebody in robotics that's a mentor
uh determine do they write up a
competency for engineering or the person
at uh the coffee shop do they write up a
competency for um I don't know counting
change or whatever they you know the
competency is how is how is that
actually done yeah so it's going to
depend upon the individual program but
we've got Statewide academic standards
and a competency is essentially a
compilation of Standards so certain
number of Standards add up to meeting a
competency the state has model
competencies that we do have available
but most of our learn everywhere
programs are borrowing uh competencies
from local schools and saying okay
here's a competency that would might be
used just as so uh if it's used by a
local school um then but the local
school doesn't actually have any in a
learn everywhere program there's not a
person from the school that actually
oversees the program like it is in an
ELO where they actually uh go out and
talk to the person in in robotics or
they they they monitor the student there
um how does the local school make sure
that their competency is being met if
they if the mentor is uh in main
blasting uh you know rock or whatever I
mean how how does how does that work
how's the uh coordination yes a great
question I appreciate that so
essentially what happens is and it's not
dissimilar to um an Extended Learning
opportunity so a student is out at a uh
you know Extended Learning opportunity
or learn everywhere program and the
program itself is acknowledging that the
student has met the competencies right
so the competencies for all the learn
everywhere programs for Extended
Learning opportunities are mapped out in
the program and they're approved by the
State Board of Education and then the
program itself is acknowledging that the
student has met those competencies so if
we were to use the example of first
robotics uh you've got Engineers from
bos or bae or Deca you know sign off and
saying like this kid can code he's got
it right he knows how to do that work
and even in an Extended Learning
opportunity an Extended Learning
opportunity coordinator is generally
relying on the program itself if a if a
student is doing a PE credit at Tokyo
Joe's right they're relying on Tokyo Joe
to be able to acknowledge that the
student has met the PE
requirements represent
pelli thank you thank you for being here
commissioner um I'm just wondering um
the last part of the bill how do you
envision the State Board of Education
annually determining if these 800
entities comply with state and federal
anti-discrimination laws so so I'm not
sure that that would be possible for
anyone you would have to actually go in
and do a have a full-fledged monitoring
program um you know because it depends
on what you anticipate as a as
legislature when you say the State Board
of Education shall annually review all
entities does that mean that I send a
team of individual ual to each of these
800 plus businesses um you know to allow
that to happen I'm not sure that that's
going to be possible um you know we've
got a uh I believe it's called kigo is
one of our foreign language programs
which is based out of Costa Rica for
Spanish language program uh so I'll go
to Costa Rica uh in Winter and and
monitor that particular program but so
I'm not sure what you're anticipating
there but it does feel a bit unworkable
you San Jose itd be kind of fun it might
be fun in the winter representa Cornell
Thank you thank you for taking my
question I can't find learn anywhere on
the state department the department of
education's website because I want to
look and see you know how many students
are getting credits at their schools for
for what do you know what to look under
sure if you just go under education
programming there's this and it's called
Uh there's two places that you can
navigate to it I think it's called
learning outside of school and then
under that you'll find one of them is
about learn everywhere okay and and that
will tell me what it will provide all
the information that we have relative to
the program yes okay so we do have a
list of what schools are granting credit
to students and we publish that every
year in September okay thank you further
question representa
Woodcock thank you chair commissioner
good morning good morning still than
still let's get it done yes a pleasure
to see you here it's infrequent I'm glad
you're here uh you you were discussing
the curriculum competencies and the
coordination between the elos and the
external learning to those
in terms of our curriculum competencies
and from the state house from the doe uh
and all our curriculum areas can you
just give us a quick snapshot of where
they are in 2024 how updated they are
how frequent they are are they all I'm
not sure I understand the question maybe
you could repeat that curriculum
standards in the corer academic
standards schools academic standards can
you tell us and people use those the
guides um where we are in terms of
updating or how current they are in in
AC yes so they're in various you know
ages depending on uh you know when they
were last adopted you know so math and
we use the Common Core St academic
standards for Math and English language
arts and that was in 2012 adopted I
believe in 2014 um we've got other
standards and I don't know the dates for
each of the other standard areas but
probably older than that okay so if mat
yes thank you so for that same in the
same line thinking then so if schools
are trying to and I'm not trying to jam
you up here if schools are trying to
follow these okay wait if chairman will
stop me if the schools are trying to
follow these competencies and they're
already a decade behind Yeah by your own
admission and which is fine they decade
behind how are we going to get or when
are these schools going to get current
competencies like the social science or
math or English we just talking about
that are 2024 and Beyond if we're
already decade behind now where are we
in the revision piece yeah so what I can
tell you is that you have to understand
that you know these are academic
standards which truthfully have not
don't need and have not Chang
substantively for decades and the math
that you learned is much of the same
math that we want our kids to learn
today uh so whether it was a math
standard that was written in 1950 or in
1960 or 1970 or in 2012 you'll see if
you go read those standards you know in
the younger grades we wanted to have
basic numeracy we want to be able to do
addition and subtraction as they get
further Advanced we went on to do you
know like some statistics and algebra
and then we get into trigonometry so uh
much of the content standards are stuff
that we expect our students to be to go
to school to learn and there's not
that's not an area that you have some
rapid evolution in okay and pleas yeah
last one thank thank you Mr chairman
across the state um are you comfort how
comfortable you saying that across the
state our school are currently fallowing
competencies um so I know that that is
the um the rule that they're required to
uh award Credits based on students uh
achieving competencies so that is the
system that they are supposed to be
implementing last one last Point wait a
minute the last one was the last
one I won't do more this you got a proxy
from somebody else here yes go for
it so just just back to that that
comment CP done so if the schools if the
schools are doing that um and they're
supposed to be doing that my question
view is and we hear frequently from
school folks that are here that their
schools are not doing that so my
question is how how does the doe
oversight besid the spok to I don't say
the spokes to be but how do they
actually go and monitor or regulate that
they are doing those compens yeah so
it's principally through we basically
have an output accountability system
associated with students assessment and
then we have a input accountability
system which is pbass where schools are
reporting to us what they are doing um
and then we follow up on that okay thank
thank you Mr chair with represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question it's a followup to
part of Representative woodcock's um
inquiries so I appreciate your response
that for example in math what we need to
teach has not changed for decades
probably but as a science
and a historian I think what we would
want to be teaching in 2024 there's a
much greater body of
knowledge than there was in 2000 or
1980s so where are we at on updating
those standards so I believe that the
ngss standards were adopted by the State
Board of Education in
2017 so they are more current so you
know a body a a standard that needs a
more frequent refreshing is probably
going to be more refreshed than
something that doesn't to your point so
2017 I believe was when they were last
adopted further questions from the
committee represent Tanner so I just I
want to kind of get back to the bill
itself and about the anti-discrimination
and again that 354 deals with employees
and
employers and and as you said the
customers coming in but our
non-discrimination laws under 193 are
quite different um because they apply to
students and the right of a student to
get an adequate education and a few
other things and I'm just wondering and
I think if if I had you write if I read
if I was hearing what you were saying
was that you just think it would be too
cumbersome for uh people that the like
the Builder that this that that the kid
went to um that it would be too
cumbersome for them to
um to to write a pol to follow this the
193 policy and uh that that's your main
objection to this bill is that was I
hearing that correctly so I just want to
correct the record because you indicated
that uh 354a doesn't apply when in fact
19339 specifically references
354a um stating that each school
district and Charter Public School shall
develop a policy that guides the
development and implementation of a
coordinated plan to prevent assess uh
the presence of intervene in and respond
to incidences of discrimination um on
the basis of age sex gender identity
sexual orientation race color marital
status familial status disability
religion national origin or any other
class protected under
354a and so 354a is an anti and 354 is
an anti-discrimination statute which
applies to our schools like if a student
walks into a school and somebody says
you know and they discriminate them
based upon religion right that is a 354
violation and that school and whoever
perpetrates that honor would be in
violation of discrimination ation
subject to the provisions of that
statute the statute that you're
referring to here requires our public
schools to as it says each School
District shall develop a policy that
guides for the development and
implementation of a coordinated plan to
prevent blah BL blah right and so what
I'm saying is that that is going to be
an obstacle if I go to FedEx and I say
to FedEx in londondary I want you to
implement this policy FedEx and lunder
is not going to be able to they're going
to have to go back to corporate
headquarters in Tennessee they're going
to have to talk to Tennessee to see
whether they can get it and essentially
what's going to happen is this become
this bureaucracy that probably it won't
happen and students will not be able to
go there and I think that you will find
that same effect when you try to impose
a school policy requirement on
Commercial entities that are already by
Statute prevented from discrimination so
again a solution looking for a
problem but thank you very much there
further questions from the committee
representative
Hall so I'm going to go back to that
contractor one more time I think this
third time here uh does that person have
to apply any paperwork that goes along
with that kid going to the contractor so
if we're referring to learn everywhere
program so every learn everywhere
program has to come to the State Board
of Education they fill out a complete
application um it is reviewed by the
State Board of Education it was
interesting there was a comment that
indicated somebody said that um somebody
was approved as learn everywhere and
didn't go through the process and I can
tell you that that's 100% false that's
never happened for any learn everywhere
program the State Board of Education
gets so first of all I have to sign off
on the application then the applications
go to the State Board of Education
Without the application the State Board
would have nothing to act on so uh they
have to fill out an application it
enumerates the program it enumerates the
policies of their organization it
enumerates the uh you know the um you
know the credits that are earned and the
competencies and how they'll be earned
that is voted on by the State Board of
Education they get what's referred to as
a provisional license under the current
rules um after a year we go back and we
revisit the program make sure they're
doing exactly what they told us they
were doing if they are then they get a
renewal for a fiveyear Orient you know
fiveyear renewal process just like all
of the schools at that point in time so
they have quite a bit of followup and
and Assurance to make sure they're
actually doing what they told us that
they would do and I think there was a
question over here we've not had
complaints about discrimination in these
programs
quick
followup is is are there questions about
anti-discrimination on that
application um I believe that the rules
require them to comply with RSA 354
exactly thank you thank you further
questions from the committee not seeing
any thank you very much thank you and we
have no other cards so we're going to
close this
hearing and we'll pick it up again at
1:00 and we have a l caucus and there's
a one o00 caucus in here 12 o' excuse me
12 o'clock yeah yeah
lunch
e
okay we're ready to go ahead here for
the afternoon hearings uh we're going to
open up the hearing right now for uh
1093 uh 1093 is a bill prohibiting
mandatory mask policies in schools and
I'd like to welcome representative
Noble good afternoon chairman lad and
members of the committee my name is
Kristen Noble and I represent Hillsboro
District 2 the town of
Bedford
I'm bringing this bill forward for two
reasons one is to make sure that
children are never forced to wear a mask
to attend school ever again and two to
hopefully rebuild some of the trust that
was lost between parents and the
schools there should be no question now
that it wasn't just the lockdowns that
were detrimental to children but forcing
them to wear masks also had serious and
Lasting
consequences masking kids had a negative
impact on their learning their speech
their mental and emotional well-being
their physical health and their Social
Development if you didn't have kids in
the public school at that time as I did
you may not know what kids went through
besides the remote learning and The
Masks so so we had several mental health
work sessions in here and
um that kind of triggered me to to ask
the parents um that I was still
connected to from from back then we
still have a group text and I asked them
to remind me of some of the things that
our kids went through during that
time so U let me just summarize that for
you they were made to wear masks for
hours a day in school school on the bus
during gym class at recess
outdoors and even while playing
instruments students were repeatedly
told that they would get their family
members sick if they didn't keep their
masks
up at lunch they had to sit far apart
from their friends separated by
plexiglass or
cardboard some schools made them keep
their masks up when not actively eating
or drinking
at recess they had to play in zones not
able to cross the lines to see their
friends in addition to their
education they were robbed of their
Sports their proms their field trips
their
friends their routines and
stability kids developed severe anxiety
and depression Eating Disorders some
were even at risk of
suicide I feel it's important to share
this with you because at times I I I do
hear that there's a little irritation
with parents sometimes I hear that in
here and and I understand that it it's
been a difficult situation for everybody
um but I feel that uh it things have
kind of snowballed a
bit so I just want you to understand the
parent perspective
and I want you to know that we felt
helpless watching our
kids go through
this and that is the source of a lot of
anger that you
see we knew that this was a catastrophe
for kids and it fell on deaf ears all
over the
state the state did not have a mask
mandate for schools
K through 12 students and teachers were
exempt from the governor's mask
mandate yet no District that I know of
stuck to that and just went with
personal
choice they created the Mandate
themselves which was also allowed under
the governor's
order in August of last year as kids
were heading off to college covid cases
were on the rise and a lot of colleges
and universities around the country were
imposing mask mandates again this caused
quite a bit of anxiety with parents of
younger kids because they did not want
their kids masked
again so I decided to put this bill
in uh some of you have seen this bill
before it's um HB 1131 from
2022 it's not the bill as introduced
though it's the um Senate Amendment so
it doesn't have any penalties or
anything like
that
this bill does not stop anyone from
wearing a mask if they choose it just
ensures that it will always be left up
to parents to decide whether or not to
mask their
children I think passing this bill would
be a huge step in rebuilding trust which
really needs to happen and I hope you
will support it thank you thank you very
much for your testimony are there any
questions from the
committee
not seeing it thank you very much wow
thanks guys you got off the
hook everybody knows
[Music]
now represent cordello you're up deck or
on now
up
for the record I am Arlene Corell
representing
Atkinson um Mr chair thank you Mr chair
may I have five minutes or
how is five minutes okay otherwise I put
a time limit on speaking today
um so you'll see going around there is
my testimony and um there's a very long
bibliography at the end I wanted to show
you all of my
sources um
because I you know I agree with
representative Noble 100% and her
testimony was very emotional um I am
going to focus on sort of The Logical
evidence we've heard that phrase
following the science and that's what I
am going to do for the next 5
minutes so to
begin um there was an article I read
from the prestigious Journal of the
Royal Society of medicine and it
concluded that
quote overall there is a lack of
substantial evidence to support claims
that face masks protect from infectious
contamination now in that quote as I
quoted it there's some dot dot dot
ellipses
I want to tell you what I left out I
also want to tell you something else
surprising there's a couple of
surprising
details first that article was written
in 2015 5 years before the covid
pandemic and second the words I left out
the complete quote is overall there's a
lack of substantial evidence to support
claims that face masks protect either
patient or surgeon from infectious
contamination the title of the article
is unmasking the surgeons the
evidence-based behind the use of face
masks in surgery so this article shows
that there was skepticism regarding the
efficacy of face masks years before Co
even among
surgeons my own skepticism about face
masks began when I saw a video showing a
man outside wearing multiple face masks
of all different varieties when he
breathes no matter what type of mask or
how many masks he was wearing you could
see his breath The Masks were apparently
useless and containing the water vapor
upon which microorganisms
travel Dr Harvey R Professor emitis
ritis I'm sorry I'm not pronouncing that
correctly of epidemiology at Yale has
said that wearing masks to block virus
is like quote putting up a chain link
fence and hoping that it blocks
mosquitoes even Dr Anthony fouchy in a
February 5th 2020 email wrote quote the
typical face the typical mask you buy in
the drugstore is not really effective in
keeping out virus which is small enough
to pass through the material a Cochran
Institute study I don't mean to
overwhelm you I'm just there's not not
too much more here a Cochran Institute
Study last year concluded that quote
wearing masks in the community probably
makes little or no difference to the
outcome of covid-19 like illness
compared to not wearing
masks okay so all of this shows that it
brings into Reasonable Doubt I'm not
here to prove this is a reasonable
substantial reasonable doubt that masss
are
ineffective beyond that there has been
proven
harm there was a study in epidemiology
and infection and it actually suggested
that wearing a face mask may be
associated with an increased risk of
infection um another article I saw about
k95 Mass said that they contained
Dreadful things um toxic volatile
organic compounds and these substances
have been linked to seizures and Cancers
with concentrations eight times the
acceptable safety limits something
called I don't even know if I'm
pronouncing this right cuz you know
I'm not a not a doctor okay but I for
some reason started reading a lot of
medical journal articles because
that's just what I felt I needed to do
phthalates these are widely used
chemicals that disrupt human endoc
systems and impact human health these
have been found in face masks as have
some terrible the words like
microplastics nanoparticles um in the
Journal of hazardous materials there was
a couple of Articles um finally uh just
two more
articles one of one of the Articles um
was about mask induced exhaustion
syndrome which sounded Dreadful and I
thought that that can't be good
um the article that I just want to
finish with was actually written just in
December three months ago
and I urge you perhaps I will send you
all an email just with a link to this
one article because I think we all
should read it it's from The Archives of
disease in childhood published December
23rd uh TW I'm sorry 2023 child mask
mandates for covid-19 a systematic
review
the study concluded quote real world I'm
going to quote sort of longer here
because this is really important real
world effectiveness of child mask
mandates has not been demonstrated with
high quality evidence the current body
of scientific data does not support
masking children for protection against
covid-19 we fail to find any evidence of
benefit from masking children child mask
mandates fail a basic risk benefit
analysis recommending recommending child
masking is unsupported by current
scientific data and inconsistent with
accepted ethical
Norms this point that the study goes on
it points out a lot of the negative
effects of masking we've heard a lot of
these speech delays language learning
mental health issues all sorts of
physical
problems
representative Noble referred to a bill
a couple of years ago like this we've
learned so much more I don't know how we
can deny that there's Reasonable Doubt
about
masks
um this bill will not stop anyone who
wants to wear a mask from doing so those
people who truly believe that face masks
are an effective way to prevent the
transmission of contagious diseases can
certainly keep wearing them
parents who want their kids to wear
masks if that if a situation should
arise in which that becomes a thing
again I don't see the CH children
wearing them much but uh that they can
send them to school wearing the masks
and if they believe the masks are so
effective then they should also believe
that these masks will offer protection
against anyone choosing not to wear a
mask meanwhile reasonable doubts have
been raised by reputable sources a whole
folder here sorts of bookmarks on my
computer reasonable doubts have been
raised about the benefits of maske
wearing especially among children and
because of these reasonable doubts mask
wearing should not be required in school
and HB 1093 ought to
pass thank you very much and I would be
happy to answer your questions but
please remember I'm not a doctor I just
read a lot of medical journal articles
so thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
not seeing it you're off the
hook okay yes uh theres thank you um
yeah yeah yeah can you hear me now y
teres bastor Ash loud in New Hampshire
thank you for your time in this
afternoon I come to you my vocation is
as a nurse um but I come to you also as
a foster mom who adopted my two little
boys Max and brat who were they're now
nine and 10 so they're about six seven
seven and eight during the pandemic um
max came to me um non-verbal and so of
course being able to see lips and
working through speech therapy was a big
part of his IEP but it was really Brett
the older one that took the biggest hit
with this he was born four months
premature drug addict and his nervous
system naturally um you know is very
sensitive so he was getting in trouble
at school because he would chew on his
mask um his mask would come home
stopping wet with you know as a
clinician anything that's warm dark
moist and you know naturally sugary is
our saliva is a breeding Pichu dish for
bacteria we also become mouth breathers
when we put a mask on where our our Nars
our nostrils have little filaments to
help clean before it gets into our body
so we're kind of bypassing Nature's
natural defense but here he is all day
long he would come home his mask was so
dirty so wet so disgusting and he was
getting in trouble time and time again
for chewing on his mask his teachers
were sending me home that they keep
telling him he's not listening so then
he started
flapping just like a nervous Tech so we
had to go through all his autistic
what's going on all of that just in the
last 8 months has completely vanished
but it took us a year and a half for the
nervous tick and he would go you know St
the night with somebody and be like I'm
a flapper and they thought he was
talking about you know that he farted or
you know and he was like no I get EX you
know so his nervous system because of
the stress of this child wanting to
please the adults knowing that he was
chewing on his mask and continually
getting in trouble for that it came to a
point the teacher was like we'll just
pull it down over your face and to me as
a parent if we're teaching children that
this is the rules but then we're also
teaching them it's okay to break the
rules that's also sending a bad message
to our children and that was happening
throughout the school districts so in my
opinion my experience with my two
children would be let me as the parent
decide let me discern what the risk
reward is for my child to have the m
mask on to prevent them from Contracting
a virus from someone else but when it's
wet they're touching it mask when we go
through our clinicals as clinicians
we're taught to Dawn on and Dawn off
with each
transaction you don't wear the same
gloves and the same mask all day long
and you know that was something that I
never understood through the pandemic
because it was like everything we had
been taught went out the window and yet
we're letting our children go without
any training about touching their face
touching here touching here it actually
in my opinion I believe it probably made
the spread of the virus worse than
better but if parents wanted to mask
their children certainly their
prerogative but to deny other children
from their learning experience and let
us as parents discern what is right and
best for our children when we're paying
to have them educated and they have the
right to be educated I would really hope
that going forward should be ever come
against another pandemic that you would
allow the parents to discern what is
emotionally mentally physically heart
mind and body best for their child and
their learning environment thank you for
your time thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee
represent
Woodcock good afternoon than question um
did you ever go to your local school
board and ask them about this yes very
much we actually have a large group um
that showed up pretty uh thank you yes
you're welcome further questions from
the committee thank you very much you're
welcome uh Max
SCD good afternoon
afternoon it's uh incredible to me that
we're still uh on this topic uh four
years later but um I'd just like to
First address a couple of things that
the representatives have already said so
far about masks and their purpose um the
analogy was made of a chain link fence
for Mas well actually sorry backing up
first masks are not purely about
reducing incoming viruses to you it's
about reducing the amount that spreads
to others so all this focus on masks as
being you know sure you can send your
own kid with a mask but it the
effectiveness of a mask is through the
General like the more people wearing
them the more effective they will be
because it's about reducing transmission
to others um the chainlink fence analogy
made about masks um is inaccurate
because yes a virus itself is very small
and yes is is at that scale of the chain
link fence analogy but the viruses are
not contain you know they're not
floating in the atmosphere alone they're
floating on water droplets and it's
those water droplets that are much
bigger and and are being caught by The
Mask um
additionally um there was some unclear
wording I think in the actual bill of
this text um saying uh there was sorry
like can I just bring it up on my phone
the first thing was saying um there was
a phrase unless another law uh is here
uh sorry um or is required by some other
section of the law um um I just have
questions about what does that mean does
that mean that just another law saying a
mask enforcement would uh you know
supersede this law um I have a further
question of um it says
uh the other exception here is is sports
related equipment um and it says or
while where uh or to wear protective
equipment while handling chemicals fire
or other similar hazardous elements I a
question about what does uh handling
mean in this case does this mean if you
were next to hazardous elements but not
handling them uh I think there's just
some vagueness with the wording there um
as well as other similar hazardous
elements what does that entail what are
other similar hazardous elements that
just seems very vague to me uh would
other uh similar hazardous elements
include like things like rock dust
something that is extremely necessary uh
and this this get back to the purpose of
masks masks um there are two levels of
like protective masks um or well there's
many more but there's like the higher
level m95 masks which really actually do
not 100% but much more than the medical
masks the blue ones um actually do
reduce incoming particles and that can
be very uh necessary um for any sort of
rock dust uh
hazardous particulate matter um and this
bill you know seems to have an exception
carved out for that but its lack of
specificity on hazardous elements uh and
handling uh what would that mean because
wouldn't hazardous elements I assume
doesn't mean literally the periodic
table of elements um so would a
hazardous element be a
virus you know like it I just feel like
the carve out for has elements there
just needs more specificity in general
but uh in general I just yeah and to
close I just can't believe we're still
having this uh conversation about the
effectiveness and like use cases of
masks um and then it's just entirely
brought to this like point of view of
that it's a issue of freedom and
without uh taking to account uh Public
Health is uh you know I I I just the
it's completely missing the point of
masks I'd say but I love any questions
um that's all I have thank you very much
for your testimony are there any
questions from the committee yes
represent Terry thank you so you covered
a lot of ground but I'd like to return
for a moment to the disagreement that
you have apparently have with Dr Harvey
R uh with respect to the he was the he
was the uh the academic uh who made the
state the epidemiologist who made the
statement with respect to the fence and
the mosquitoes I'm just wondering if you
have uh Avail yourself of the
opportunity to be in conversation with
him and an attempt to try to determine
whether you you and he can find some
common ground are you I'm sorry I'm not
quite understanding your question sir um
are you you appear to be disagreeing
with Dr Harvey rich and I'm not sure if
I am but I'm not familiar enough with
his spec his specific statements to know
if I'm disagreeing with him or not but
you cited his statement and said you
disag I know and I'm trying to get to
your point sir um so are you suggesting
that he's not saying that the chain link
fence only applies to the actual
particulate size are you saying he in uh
that he is acknowledging that okay that
the viruses that are contained within
water droplet material that that
wouldn't pass through his chain link
fence actually only saying about the
actual virus itself well actually I'm
I'm asking you if you've had that
conversation with him not with me I'm
not Dr Harvey Rich I just asked I have
to have you or not I'm asking you is
what his statement is because I I don't
have his statement in front of me right
now um so I'm not sure okay so you
disagree with him but you've I'm saying
I don't know what his statement exactly
is so I'm not sure thank you thank
you further questions represent
beler thank you Mr chair and I I wanted
to turn to uh the testimony cuz it it it
was surprising to me a little bit when
you said that covid um is transmitted on
droplets of water within droplets water
within droplets of water which so I have
a background in healthcare I was a
paramedic for quite a while and we have
different precautions that we take
depending on whether something is
Airborne or droplet born so are still as
far as I'm aware aerosolized uh
virus particles I'm sorry I'm not sure
the correct terminology there um as far
as I'm aware even the aerosolized
version are still within a water droplet
it's not the virus free
floating thank you further questions
from the committee represent
Pell thank you thank you for taking my
question I may have missed your
introduction but do you have a medical
background or a science background or
anything nope so this is just your
personal opinion thank you yes it is um
I would add that a few months prior to
the pandemic uh was for my job uh using
a Crosscut saw while wearing m95 mask um
for hours um so as as far as any I think
I heard one of the representatives
mention um mask fatigue something I I
there wasn't much explanation attached
to that but um I just I would throw that
in for uh just a personal anecdote of
that it's quite possible to wear
a highle mask and still do physical
activity represent dry thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
abut so I'm playing clerk today and you
didn't check whether you support or
opposed the bill no I did not didn't I
didn't I didn't check it
ohos but wondering if the the things you
brought up if you addressed those would
that make it more amenable to you um I
would have to see how it's addressed but
I think uh more generally speaking um an
outright ban on on mask policies I think
is probably a step too far still but
with the bill as written I have specific
concerns to those uh those issues of
vagueness thank you are there further
questions from the committee not seeing
thank you very much thank you uh Kitty
are you is there Kitty
here
welcome thank you good afternoon my name
is Kitty motti I'm from der New
Hampshire and i would support this bill
um as an educator during the pandemic
teaching children to read was very
difficult I worked at an outdoor school
and even though we
had gone through a lot of steps to
ensure the safety of our children we
were still as teachers wearing a mask
and our little kiddos were around
delightful little campfires and it
looked very romantic I'm sure from the
outside but attempting to teach
different pronunciations of words was
very difficult and um even though we
tried to stay in person and we did as
much as we possibly could to influence
education in a positive way many of our
kiddos still fell
behind secondly I think this is a really
exciting bill because very rarely do we
have the opportunity to protect the
kiddos who are here it frustrates me to
no end that children are not usually in
the rooms where laws are being made to
decide what their behavior will or will
not have to be there are some here today
and I'm really grateful that they have
come and I think this is a wonderful
opportunity for all of you who have been
elected by their parents to show them
that they matter to you that their
decision making that their freedoms
matter to you that you believe as their
elected officials who represent them
even though they cannot vote for you you
have an incredible chance to show them
hey you know what we do trust in your
parents ability to make this call we do
want to protect the freedoms that you
guys are going to have to fight for
later on and this bill would enable you
them to know that for you guys to say
you know what we're not going to make
this demand from on high we're going to
let you all decide for yourselves a few
years ago one of my favorite bills came
through the New Hampshire State
Legislature and it was a reactive Bill
to something ridiculous that happened I
think in Pennsylvania where a 9-year-old
girl's hus not husband excuse me father
had been arrested because she was trying
to have a lemonade stand and a police
officer came by and said hey you don't
have a permit for this and the dad
naturally was
upset the dad ended up getting arrested
and New Hampshire came forward and said
we don't want that to happen here we're
going to make sure that little
entrepreneurs can be little
entrepreneurs and we passed a bill that
protected a kid's right to have a
lemonade stand I would like to see that
happen again thank you thank you very
much for coming today are there any
questions from the
committee yes this is a committee where
kids do testify we had 315 people here
for homeschooling homeschooling Bill
yesterday good portion were youngsters
many of them were my students yeah I'm
very proud of them uh Miss
Osborne welcome back thank you good
afternoon my name is aan Osborne I'm a
17-year-old student from Auburn New
Hampshire for at least two solid years
during the corona virus outbreak New
Hampshire citizens everywhere were
subjected to the tyranny of mask
mandates I remember all too well how
young children could not even attend
school without being forced to cover
their faces we were told these mandates
were for our own safety that we were
protecting our fellows by complying with
these Statewide demands it wasn't about
safety it was about control if the state
is per permitted to raise its children
in this way to groom them to comply with
anything they say even something as
simple as covering their faces what kind
of society does that create certainly
not one of logical independent thinkers
no it creates a hive mind a society of
complacent subservient sheep the era of
mask mandates must never again be
allowed to resurface young children
should never again be raised in an
environment where they are punished
simply for the decision to or not to
wear a face covering parents shouldn't
even be allowed to force a mask on their
child it's essentially child abuse and
if parents shouldn't be able to do that
other should the state thank you thank
you very much are there any
questions thank you very much uh
represent mlay
Phillips good afternoon everyone thank
you um I am representative Emily
Phillips uh representing Fremont New
Hampshire inham district 7 so um I'm
thrilled to be here because it's the
reason why I ran for office honestly uh
I was on the school board in Fremont uh
in 2019 and I got this whammer whammy of
a a covid pandemic to unroll during my
first time as Schoolboard member and my
district was a little unique we uh
adopted a facal coverings policy before
we opened in the fall in a compared to
other districts around us a lot of
people were going either uh virtual or a
um you know half the kids some days half
kids others so we actually opened in
person we were a k through eight um
district and we were able to pass a uh
policy called facial covering so um
parents had the option of using cloth
face masks disposable masks or plastic
face Shields um I for my own children I
have three children now but at the time
I had two um two of my children are
severely uh disabled special ed and so I
wrote uh to the principal and saying my
children will be wearing plastic face
Shields and it um the reason I gave um
not that I was required to but I gave
reasons based on their IEP goals that
were extensive that would be unable to
be met if their faces were covered um a
lot of it was speech and language
related so um my children went to school
and I'm thankful for that in the fall of
2020 um I had actually tried during the
summer to get my then kindergartener and
first grader to wear masks and they were
not able to do so obviously and they
were you know expressing discomfort they
weren't they were barely talking as it
is without the mask but um so we wor
plastic face Shields to school um in
November of 20120 we were on vacation um
and again I'm on the school board at
this time and I get a call from my
superintendent while I'm in Florida and
I said hey um the governor just issued a
math mandate so your kids can't come
back to school after vacation and I said
what you can't you can't say that and my
superintendent was like yeah you can't
and then she had not read the full order
and realized that it did not apply to K
through 12 schools so she later the day
after calling the Department of
Education riged on that and said your
kids can come back with their plastic
face shield so that was the first time
that was just um Insanity um my daughter
uh we repeated her in kindergarten after
doing her first year in kindergarten
with the whole Mass policy going on um
she formed no connections with other
students she was completely non-verbal
at school um she was not speaking I
think primarily because she could not
see the mouth and lip shape shapes of
like her SLP providers her classmates
she just did not speak um there's
something called a like a sound wall you
could put up of images of how to make
the the you know the sound s or the
sound p with your mouth so she was not
seeing that from her peers she was
wearing a plastic face shield Her speech
and language providers were not wearing
um the clear masks that were coming out
you know for being pushed they were
still distancing themselves and trying
to teach my child how to talk without
showing their face so it's a little
frustrating
um masks became optional in the fall of
2021 in my district so um some kids wore
them some kids didn't um there was a
high viral load in our area where all of
a sudden in October my school board
decided we're going to make it or it
wasn't even a school board I think it
was a superintendent who decided
randomly we're going to implement mass
for the next two weeks so I pulled my
daughter out because she was already
like just burnt out I was like she
cannot be around kids with the mask on
she was not talking to anyone she was
making no progress it was it was almost
like
um she would just go to school do
nothing come home and then be just
mentally unraveling because she was it
was like so just crazy to be around
everyone with their faces covered um I
had to put her back into school because
I just couldn't manage everything and um
homeschool her for two weeks so I ended
up putting her back in um the following
year they uh the school approached me
saying they they thought she had
selective mutism um because she wasn't
speaking at school I knew her outside of
school and she could talk but she wasn't
getting any of her Services um selective
mutism is an anxiety disorder that is uh
resolved via uh medication um and um so
I wasn't really interested in that I I
want to skip to my son for a second but
uh my son at the same time was in second
grade during 2020 and he wore a plastic
face shield uh he he may have been the
only kid in his class wearing one he was
asked a partner with another student in
his classroom that the child raised his
hand and said miss teacher I don't want
to work with Colin because he doesn't
wear a face mask so the teachers used
that moment and said okay I'm going to
sign sign you to someone else Colin
instead of using that moment to say
Colin is clean Colin is safe everyone is
safe here you can work together she did
not use that moment correctly I did not
find this out from my son I found it out
from another parent of a a classmate and
my son was very upset when I brought it
up cuz he knew i' would be mad so that's
why he didn't tell me um so in um
invisible disabilities become very
visible when you have these face masks
there are kids who can't wear them so I
was wearing a PL my child was wearing a
plastic face shield so he has he looked
different but there there are children
who really can't wear this adults can't
wear these masks so when you implement
these mandates it's just it's it's so
divisive I can't even explain it um so
I'm very shook up as a parent who went
through this but
um I pulled both my children out in 2022
like I said they were trying to medicate
my daughter or diagnose her with a
condition that's only solv through
medication uh for anxiety so I I
homeschooled last year and I had to work
and I had to be a State Rep so I put
them in a co-op four days a week I paid
$950 a month for my kids to go somewhere
else during the day so I could come here
or I could go to my job I ran out of
money so they're back in public charter
school and I love the charter school and
we're in a different time now right and
so there are no kids wearing masks and
they're not being told to cover their
mouths and I appreciate that but I'm
trying to prevent it from happening
again because people on school boards
are not qualified to make this decision
um my daughter is speaking and she is
reading and both my kids were retained
because I knew better than to send them
back two years delayed um they are
thriving in their public charter school
and I'm thrilled for that and she does
not have an anxiety disorder she is
happy and she's connecting with people
when we talk about local Authority and I
think that's why the bill was vetoed
there is nothing more local than a
family and an individual Choice okay and
that's what I want to happen we do not
override parental Choice Family Choice
individual choice so again we're talking
about kids with mask mandates not adults
so I don't want to hear the argument
that I can wear a mask all day and I'm
fine because kids are not the same every
kid is individual happy to take
questions thank you thank you very much
are there any
questions you have to be pretty
dedicated to spend 900 plus bucks to
receive a salary that's $100 yeah that
was just I was trying to save my kids it
was a mental health year for us and we
loved homeschooling it was great it's
just I not everyone can do it with you
know if I'm not home I can't educate
them so I had to send them somewhere
it's just a expensive thanks thank you
you're
welcome
uh see Barrett Christina and then we
have one other card after that on this
one oh another
one
okay thank you chairman lad good
afternoon members of the committee bar
Christina from the School Board
Association I suppose somebody has to be
the contrarian on this Bill and it
usually falls on me so here we are um we
are opposed to the bill um two quick
notes um first um though she's no longer
on the school board I would like to um
thank representative Phillips for her
prior work on her local school board and
also one of the last things that she
said I think is is important to um take
into consideration when we go back to
March of 2020 representative Philip said
that school boards are not qualified to
make these decisions nhba could not
agree more which is why I think this
bill perhaps maybe a little misguided in
terms of directing um the it's not a
mandate I guess a Prohibition towards
local school boards when local school
boards adopted or implemented masking
policies after we returned to school I
guess it was fall of
20021 those were under executive order
from from the governor um I think I have
it here um this is executive order I'm
sorry set 74 um this may be the older
one but it's you know it it's in order
requiring persons to wear masks or cloth
face coverings when in public spaces
without physical or social distancing
that was an executive order from the
governor's office that was not a
decision of a local school board um you
know in in New Hampshire um also June
2021 New Hampshire health and education
leaders issu joint statements on masks
here's a picture of the governor
Commissioner of education and uh Dr Chan
it says while K12 school this is the
guidance the school board school boards
across the state we're getting while K12
schools continue to have the ability to
set face mask policies for covid-19
prevention the New Hampshire Department
of Education and division of Public
Health Services recommend that there
should be flexibility in school fath
mask policies so that if situations
arise where it becomes potentially
unsafe to wear a face mask for a
prolonged period of time that steps be
taken to allow Mass to come off even in
indoor environments the the New
Hampshire division of Public Health is
in the process of updating their General
face mask guidance so we have a
statement that's saying well we're not
sure what we want you to do and we'll
get back to you meanwhile schools are
still trying to do what they're trying
to do and school boards are trying to
spend hours and hours and hours
developing plans listening to the CDC
listening to the what the state
epidemiologist listening to the governor
listening to the Department of educ
education so further on I think I've got
the the I believe it was representative
Phillips also mentioned this is May of
2023 to new new sites need to protect
local control in veto of of of Bill
Banning Mass decisions so I just wanted
to be clear that it local school boards
were developing their protocols and
policies relative to masking inperson or
remote social distancing School busing
based on the guidance that the
professionals were telling us it wasn't
just Joe Schoolboard member a particular
Schoolboard in a in a member in a
community that thought a mask was a
great idea nobody wanted to wear a mask
we understood that you know the
challenges that it was having kids
little kids 5 6 7 years old all day long
trying to wear a mask that was the
guidance that we were given so um you
know I I I I could go on and on there
are a handful of Court decisions in from
New Hampshire um you know masking was
being called child restraint under RSU
RSA 126 D and I think it's you know
important to note that if this is the
hollbrook line
case when since simply put RSC chapter
126 you has no bearing on the legality
of the school district's Mass mandates
the plaintiff's argument to the contrary
is based on a twisted and tortured
reading of the statute
this is very important it is an affront
to children who have actually been
subject to unnecessary and dangerous
physical restraints while at school
because that was the argument that was
being made three years ago um anyway you
know the other thing too is no we don't
have mask mandates I don't know of any
school district that has a mask mandate
anymore you know we're addressing
something you know
retrospectively that hasn't been in
place in the state in in in in in two
plus years um so I just you know if if
if an amendment needs to be brought
forth that the governor cannot issue an
executive order mandating masks and that
the Department of Health and Human
Services or whoever it is can't put out
guidance recommending people wear masks
nhba would have no objection to that
because that's not within our purview
but you know it was not local school
districts and it was not local school
boards that were making these decisions
we were listening to the commissioner
the governor CDC and Dr Chan in trying
to make our decisions and trying to
identify the needs for you know whatever
160,000 kids in the state 20,000
teachers Paris professional support
staff and so on and so forth so with
that I'm I'm happy to answer any
questions are there any questions from
the committee representa
Tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my question this particular bill
is set to go into section
18910 um and as I look at it that 18910
is it's it's a new paragraph obviously
but it's under studies so it's like with
financial literacy and with uh teaching
health education and physical education
and
um it just doesn't seem like it it fits
there and I'm just wondering if there's
another part that you might know of law
where Public Health
um is listed What what schools can and
cannot do for example when I was
teaching there was was a group of uh
exchange students that went to Soviet
Union and uh was exposed to measles and
when they got back uh several of the it
was April vacation several of them came
down with measles and so at that point
there was a public health um recommend
not a recommendation actually a demand
that if a student was in school at the
time and not vaccinated for measles they
had to stay home for a certain length of
time right um and I remember that cuz I
had a couple athletes on my tennis team
that had to stay home and couldn't play
um and I'm just wondering if that's uh
in another section of law under public
health or uh with school law sure thank
you thank you very much represent for
the question RSA 200 is health and
sanitation which relates to school
health services for example RSA 200
colon 27 school health services RSA 200
colon 27A consent of parent or legal
guardian School physician school nurse
um SCH school health personnel physical
examination of pupils um reporting
defects of uh uh or students with
disabilities um RSA 200 col 40 is
emergency care so um there's also it's
not be um let not uh loose sight of RSA
194 col 3 that puts a direct obligation
of school districts to um um protect
children relative to health and safety
standards as well too which is often
cited in a number of the lawsuits um 3
four years go relative to masking that
the district has an affirmative
obligation to protect the health and
safety of
students follow up just follow up so
this isn't in the appropriate section of
uh I mean aside from nhs's objections to
the bill I mean I it may perhaps be best
put in RSA 200 thank you other other
questions represent
leus Could you um tell me that 190
whatever one that you that last one that
you quoted 190 I'm not sure 189 col oh
I'm not sure what you're talking about
represent last one that you did I just
wanted to write the number down oh oh
I'm sorry R say 200 colon 40 Emergency
Care was that the one no there was one
um about protecting children oh I'm
sorry I say 194 colon 3 194 colon 3 yeah
and three thank you you're welcome I
think I have that right if not I you
know Becky and I can follow up with you
with a correct citation but I'm pretty
sure that's it without pulling up in Fr
further questions from the committee
representative Damon thank you Mr chair
thank you for being for taking my
question and for speaking to
this would you agree would you confirm
that knowledge of masking is different
today than it was in 2020 and 2021 yeah
thank you very much representative I
mean I mean
certainly just thinking back to the
experience that nsba was going through
and and the phone calls that nhba was
getting from school boards and and
school administrators and working in
conjunction very closely with the
Department of Education commissioner and
I were on the phone together probably
every day for a number of months at that
time you know it it it you know it was
chaos school districts were were doing
the best that they could possibly do it
was very interesting I I remember I
recall this I think Becky and I miss
Wilson and I were having a conversation
recently that when everything shut down
in March 15th or whatever it was of
2020 um I was getting more phone calls
from superintendent between say 400 p.m.
and 900 p.m. because I think during the
day they were dealing with what can they
do in our building and we got to find
the masking and and the and and another
Point too just got me going on it is
you've seen me often do in this in this
room we're talking about masks here what
about plexiglass and cleaning supplies
and all the other PPE that and masking
and gowns and and whatnot are we going
to are we going to prohibit those moving
forward I don't I don't know but you
know it wasn't just masking that was
part of
the the the mitigation efforts if you
will so I mean yeah we certainly we
certainly know now I'm not not a medical
expert I've said this I'm not an
educator I'm here to help the school
boards and the administrators navigate
whatever it is that they have to
navigate so hope that answers your
question
oh that does answer my question and I
would further
ask would you confirm that there was
never any intention to do harm to
children that it was an intent to the
state of the incomplete knowledge of the
time to protect children thank you very
much um we've talked about in local
parenes the school boards and school
districts have an affirmative obligation
to protect kids and keep kids safe when
they're under custody and control during
the school day and school districts and
school board members and superintendents
and I believe that department and health
and human services and whatever public
agencies were all doing their best to to
keep everybody safe especially
kids thank you further
questions thank you thank you oh
represent
Belcher well thank you Mr chair uh I
just wanted to clarify one item because
I know that these there were guidance
and whatnot was coming down from the
state level Dr Chan the governor and
others um but I I'm not entirely sure on
how this was dealt with as as a local
level um was it your testimony that the
school boards did not adopt policies
regarding mass or it was all coming down
from above on them yeah thank you very
much for the question um if I did say
that they did not adopt policies that
was probably an error some school boards
probably did affirmatively adopt a
policy um but that policy was certainly
based on the guidance um that they were
getting from the medical experts and
whatnot so if I did say that they did
not that was that was an error
certainly thank you very much
representative are there any further
questions thank you very much thank you
very much uh
Leah she
here
yeah hi I'm Leo Walo I'm from Manchester
I was a teacher in one of the City
Middle Schools when we went through the
pandemic and the year the full year
after that um so I'm not going to speak
to the science I'm just going to speak
to what I saw happen and the effect that
that the masks and other things it is
hard to tease things out but to the
extent that I'm able to tease out the
masks in particular I'll do that with
these three or four anecdotes the first
is of a little girl that was very sweet
tried very hard always came to school so
she was one of them that came even when
we were only allowing certain days we we
lost a third of our kids when we did
that they never came at all but she came
every day she was allowed to she sailed
into that pandemic not with the
strongest Foundation she had a high
level of anxiety as her Baseline as so
many of them do she wasn't unusual in
that she didn't do that well in school
and those two things are usually related
but she tried hard and she came every
day when
these steps were implemented I noticed
that she started to disappear from her
science classroom she would get up and
walk out or she wouldn't be there at all
even though she had not been marked as
absent for the day and one day I was
walking past her special ed room which
was all in one little pod and she was in
there and so I stopped in and I talked
to her and and um the special ed
coordinator for our pod and I was like
hey sweetie what's going on I didn't see
you today and she was incapable of
speaking she was was literally paralyzed
with fear and her special ed teacher
told me and this is a quote that the
masks frighten her to the extent that
she cannot
function and really if we stop to think
about that it might sound like hyperbole
of a little 14-year-old girl but that is
what they were for was because we were
in danger and so every face that she saw
all day long telegraphed her her the
message that she is in danger and she
couldn't function I don't know what
became of her but I know she didn't
finished the school year and I don't
know how her high school went but I bet
it was different than it would have been
otherwise the next story is a very
different one but these are archetypal
stories there are many children that fit
into these broad categories this little
girl sailed into this storm with a good
foundation she was happy she was healthy
she didn't seem to have any real
problems she wasn't
coded and when we came to the end of
that long year and it was so hot that we
were sweltering and kids were ready to
pass out and the school district said
something needs to be done because
they're going to faint and so they said
you don't have to wear the masks anymore
for the rest of this school year we were
nearing June by then or whatever and
we're on a little indoor field trip and
I'm heading upstairs to the uh to the
library with the kids and I'm side by
side with this one little girl that I
was very close with she was always
you know talk to me freely and openly
about anything and she had her mask on
and I asked her so does your um does
your mom want you to wear your mask
sweetie is she still really worried
about this and she said no my mother
gets very mad at me if I put this on and
I said are you that scared of the virus
still that you feel you need to wear the
mask and she said no I've never been
afraid of this virus and I was stumped
by that and I'm like then what is it why
would you wear it it's sweltering and
nobody says you have to and she said
because I become invisible with this on
nobody calls on me in class I don't talk
to anybody in the hallways and she
became that kid with the hair in the
face and the hood pulled tight so you
couldn't see her face now we had rules
against that in school for a good reason
because that's not social emotional
learning to check out and to
self-isolate like that she's in the but
she might as well not be and she was a
good solid student before this happened
the third story is completely different
again I was upstairs and I was uh
filling in for somebody who was out we
had to do a lot of covering I don't know
who the man was on the other side of the
desk I mean on the other side of the
wall that had a class I was up there
substituting but I know that that
teacher lost all control of himself and
was screaming in at some young boy
because his mask was underneath his
nose now I can't tell you if the kid had
done it out of defiance or if it had
been an ongoing issue with that kid or
if he was just an unlucky boy whose mask
slipped under his nose at the wrong time
I don't know but I know that if the boy
was
defiant that didn't help teachers are in
a power differential in those classrooms
by design it can't be
out but you have to be able to
deescalate a problem in a classroom and
that teacher had been terrified to the
point that he could no longer really
serve his role he called that boy names
he said hateful rotten things I mean it
was unbelievable and if it was only once
that I heard something like that I
wouldn't bring it up as an anecdote
because anybody can freak out or have a
bad day but he was not alone I heard
somebody earlier today said that these
things created divisions in these
schools and they did they pitted people
against each
other the last person whose little
anecdotal story I'll tell you was my own
so the first year it was like really
quick it was the end of the year it was
really just a long summer you know
summer break cuz nothing of any value
happened after we went remote that first
year nothing really of any value
happened the second year either to tell
you the truth but the second year was
very different because it was all year
and it was awful I had parents and I
mean that plural multiple kids parents
would get a hold of me and tell
me that their happy daughter was
suicidal these masks were no small part
of
that it created a climate of
fear kids didn't come because they were
so
scared I barely limped through that year
I became a teacher as a second career I
wanted to be a teacher
bad and I was good at it I really was
and I worked with kids that people
didn't want to work with because they
didn't like school and they were harder
kids to work with and you know what they
clicked with me and they did things for
me and they worked hard for me and in
London Dairy the word was
miraculous and I barely survived that
year and then in the
summer when that ridiculous triangle of
fear was still being trotted out oh
we're in the green today but you never
know and we could come to Yellow
tomorrow I literally had to go in and
sit across from that principal and
resign my position and told him that at
this point I feel too
guilty taking money to do this to
children ever
again now I had probably 10 years left
in me before I would have retired and I
was a I had eight years of experience I
could do my job it's a hard job and it's
getting harder every year and you need
to have a good number of years under
your belt before you're capable of doing
it and I left a decade early so I don't
know how many teachers we lost but I'll
tell you I'll bet nine out of 10 of them
only had two years left five years left
and they just took off early and you
lost some of the most capable and
competent teachers that you had in the
system we can never ever make snap
decisions like this ever again we can
worry about the science later we don't
really even have to come to a agreement
right now about whether those masks
saved one child's life I doubt
it but if we have some kind of Bubonic
plague arise we can intelligently
slowly
advisedly with the new um information
that has become available to us not be
washed away in fear you know these
school boards they have no they have no
they're always just trying to not be
sued right they're trying to not be sued
they're going to decide to do things
that they think will save them from
being sued yes we want to help the kids
yes yes we don't want to hurt them yes
we want to teach them but that man that
was here is not an educator that's not
his role his role is to make sure how
the school board doesn't get sued how
can we get through our jobs and not get
sued so why don't you do them all a
favor and put it in the law that they're
never to do anything like that again and
then they don't have to worry about
it do you have anything else no are
there any questions from the
committee thank you very much you're
welcome uh represent
Penza
yeah thank you Mr chair um
representative Kelly Penza straford
District
19 I literally feel
like um like I'm going back in time you
know before I was alleged legislator I
was an activist and I was here and I
spoke in front of you chairman lad uh
multiple times biting for this and when
that veto came I uh I lost it and I've
given you my story of my kid and my
situation and I'm not going there I was
just going to come here today and all I
was going to say is the reason why this
bill needs to be put into place is
because we can never do this
again no one no bureaucrat no school
board no teacher none of it I have
control over my children in the
upbringing in their health no
one and my kid lost so
much but the gentleman here the lobbyist
that came up I want to be very clear
these were all
recommendations so let's talk about the
governor's mask mandate
okay this order number five this order
shall not not apply to the following
Educators students and staff within K
through 12 schools any person with a
medical condition or disability that
prevents wearing a mask or other face
covering my daughter has anxiety she
could not get a mask exemption none of
this nobody was following the law they
did this on their own they did these
mandates on their own they were all
recommendations the governor never said
do this edel BL never said do that I'll
give you every bit I mean I've got a
file that you can't even imagine that
goes like a mile long I've got all of
the documentation everything we just can
never do this again that's why this bill
needs to go through if it's not in the
right section I don't know 141 what HC
or whatever it is wherever it needs to
go this has to happen we just need to
make sure we have to do better and um I
have to go back to my committee sorry um
this just gives me uh just makes me
really upset I can't believe that we're
still having these conversations if you
want to wear a mask wear a mask that's
fine this has to be choice and its
parents that's it thank you very much do
you any questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much and with that I'm going to close
down this hearing
for information uh of the for the public
we will not be executing any bills in
this committee
today so there are three bills scheduled
to start at
2:30 uh those bills will be taken up at
a later date to be
announced yeah see
uh one of
those we're going to be taking a FIV
minute
break no we don't we don't need to do
that no
no
okay we're going to go ahead and start
the last hearing for today this house
res resolution
30 okay here we are
okay this bill is urging a robust
climate education in schools including
current environmental and economic
information uh I'm looking at the number
of cards we have here is about 16 cards
here so we are going to put time limits
for 2 minutes uh several of us have to
be out at another hearing and finance by
305 today so a few of us might be
switching in and out but we're going to
go ahead and start uh Wendy Thomas the
prime sponsor of the bill is welcome to
House
Education thank you I think this is my
first time here yes it is so um I I am
going to be talking about an amendment
so I'm going to pass this out now
now for information for folks the the
prime sponsor of the bill as we conduct
things here in education we allow the
time that's necessary for the prime
sponsor to present his or her bill so it
maybe five minutes maybe three minutes
and maybe 20 minutes uh we hope you
don't go to 20 though please but but
following following that every
individual test including a senator or
represent has two
minutes thank you thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee for the record
I am representative Wendy Thomas and I
represent the town of marac Hillsboro
County District
12 we have just gone through the warmest
winter that has ever been recorded in
New Hampshire we did not reach any
Sub-Zero temps for the entire winter and
if this trend continues we also just saw
the coolest winter we will have going
forward
why are cooler temperatures necessary
for our agriculture our Wildlife
including things like
ticks with a warmer climate we are
seeing we are going to see significant
changes in our environment our summers
have become wetter and smokier due to
wildfires that are constantly burning
around the United States crops are being
affected tourism is definitely being
affected if there's no snow we have no
skiers or
snowmobilers if there's constant rainy
weather in the summer we're not going to
see hikers or
ATVs climate change is no joke we are
seeing the impacts in our state on a
daily basis we've got floods we've got
high tides we have no snow we have
increased rain and we have temperature
fluctuations the climate of New
Hampshire is changing and if we don't
prepare for a different future we are
going to be lost climate change is also
going to impact our students and their
fames amilies it's going to impact all
of us this is our future we can no
longer sit around and see what's going
to happen we need to be active we need
to take significant steps to understand
the nuts and bolts of climate change and
what we can do on an individual and on a
community level to combat it last summer
in part because of my work on resources
uh in a previous term and my continued
fight against a corporate polluter in my
town that has destroyed our water and
environment some climate change youth
Advocates from 350 NH contacted me with
an idea to update New Hampshire's
climate change
curriculum in May 2014 New Hampshire
established the state model compet
competency
standards but um that but leaves the
actual curriculum up to the school dist
the local school distri districts to
develop the specific written
curriculum times have changed since that
initial disc discussion of climate
change education in
2014 we need more information and more
topics we know more now now New
Hampshire's education standards
addressing climate change received High
marks from the National Academy of
Science but they need
updating that that was good news that we
got a a high Mark um and although we got
a B+ for climate change education the
reviewers did mention the connection
between climate change impacts and what
we can do in terms of energy and
sustainability to mitigate those risks
were were in U were not being detailed
the national Center for Science
education standards frame human
activities as a major factor in Earth's
warming this is an equivocation and
inaccurate frame that allowed for the
insertion of debate on whether factors
may be
contributing and finally they wished New
Hampshire had done a better job at
helping students recognize willful
attempts to misrepresent climate dat
data
house resolution 30 proposes changes and
additions to the current climate change
education in New Hampshire to address
these issues by including an
acknowledgement of the role of human
activities in climate change historical
background of fossil fuel's contribution
to climate change social implications of
climate change including health and
economic impacts and the impact on
social discourse this includes climate
related anxiety which is becoming common
among our youth if you're not concerned
you're not paying
attention other topics include
information about Direct Solutions to
climate change and our role in it ways
that students can make changes in their
schools and their
communities jobs that will be opening up
in the renewable energy and climate
change
Fields America's green energy Workforce
grew nearly 4% from 2021 to 2022 adding
nearly 300 ,000 jobs in New Hampshire
nearly 650 jobs were added in the Energy
Efficiency sector power generation and
other
areas the growth of clean energy and
other climate related jobs will be an
important factor in whether young people
choose to stay in New Hampshire After
High School
graduation a robust climate change
curriculum curriculum would also result
in building climate literacy among
students in New Hampshire it would
provide support for teachers in
integrating climate change in their
classrooms and it would Empower students
to engage their family and community
members in discussion around climate
change hr30 has allowed Advocates to
speak up about climate change in front
of policy makers and you are going to be
hearing from quite a few of them the
advocacy team from 350 NH has attended
Board of Education meetings and have
given presentations on why it is so
important to update the climate change
curriculum these youth Advocates have
written letters to the editor prepared
both written and verbal testimony and
plan on holding rallies to get the word
out they want to be heard let's not wait
until our only response to climate
change is disaster management this house
resolution suggests that new hampsh New
Hampshire consider changes and additions
to create a more robust climate change
curriculum in New Hampshire that gives
our youth a at the table and a say in a
future that will someday belong to
them now I've handed out uh an amendment
uh after meeting with with uh a few uh
groups we've we've changed the wording
slightly on on the house resolution so
if you look at the
amendment um we we changed number one
and then um
yes number one and then line eight uh
six and through eight um the reasons for
the changes is um we wanted to remove in
what what some felt was inflammatory
language in section one uh number one of
the of the um of the
resolution um and in the whereas
starting with line eight we just focused
more on the uh environment the
enironmental
impact the biggest change however is in
the resolve section at the bottom of the
uh house resolution where we have now
called in the Department of Health and
Human Services as well as Dees to work
collaboratively to compile and
disseminate robust climate education
curricula to schools now why would we
use DHHS and Dees for curriculum they
actually have uh there's a precedent
there's there's a few precedents Dees
and dhh s have experienced getting
health and environmental information out
to our
residents the the NH DHHS tick
curriculum kits are a great example of
free and available written material DHHS
also has and has created and
disseminated pfast guidelines for
adults and then DHHS in collaboration
with Dees has a re resource for adult
education called the New Hampshire
environmental health guide that helps
people find the appropriate State
resource or agency to address
environmental concerns so these two
agencies would be the the best to help
develop a more robust climate change
curriculum and I'm very very happy to
take any questions thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee represent cordelli U thank you
um I I think I might agree with you on
on one point anyway um that's climate
change
anxiety um see seems to me that we all
have done um quite a bit to cause
climate change anxiety um in our young
people um going back to John KY and his
book I I think his original um estimates
were that uh the planet by now would be
inhabitable because of climate change or
I guess it was called I don't know if
it's climate change or global warming I
I get confused about which term is um
proper at the moment but um don't you
think that we all um have caused um
climate related anxiety in our students
which is part of I think the so-called
mental health C crisis in our schools do
I think that we've caused it yes um I
think it exists um I think the the
example that you gave of John kry he it
he did the best job he could do with the
information he had at the time so some
of these projections fell short some of
them were over over overly optimistic um
we don't have to do anything these
students are smart they're seeing that
we just went through a winter with no
snow they're seeing that our summers are
are wetter now uh there's a farmer in my
town because of the the rainfall this
summer lost 100% of his grape crop 100%
you know if that
continues I'm going to be anxious about
it other questions from the committee
represent McDonald thank you Mr chair
and thank you so much representative for
bringing this forward I understand that
this is a resolution which is different
than a bill there's a bit of a
difference but I'm a little bit confused
as to some of the definitions within the
bill there seems to be some vag vague
wording I guess for one example what do
you mean by a robust climate education
and what's your intent and I guess how
would we Define robust
um robust to me would be filling in the
gaps and and adding what um what we have
now learned since 2014 about climate
change so bringing it up to speed that's
my that's my definition of robust
appreciate that thank
you represent Woodcock than good
afternoon good to see you again good
afternoon um if if everything went
according to how you like it to go with
this here what what would you anticipate
the fight I'm reading 13 through 17 but
forget what it says there what what do
you actually want to see what concretely
do you think can be done I what is what
do you see after this in terms of
implementing this if it could be I would
like to see DHHS and Dees form some kind
of a committee and bring in Youth and
Educators to to discuss this so that we
can we can give seats at the
table and then ultimately I would like
we're not this house resolution is not a
mandate it it is considerations okay and
so we would like to see considerations
for uh climate change curriculum issued
from D DHHS and Dees
okay what yes sir thank you and then so
the next step after that what will be
the next step in you mind yeah
um I
mean we're we're locally run all of our
school boards are local run so they have
the option of looking at these
suggestions and implementing them or not
okay I mean that's we can't this is not
once again this is not a mandate this is
simply suggestions for curriculum change
the last one yes go ahead so following
one more step from that assuming this
went there and they created the the
dialogue and the the materials is there
any reason then that the DHHS and Dees
couldn't just provide that material
those material that they happen to be
local school boards for their own
determination to use or not use I would
love to see that but that's not the way
that a lot of the towns they have local
control and that kind of thing but but I
would love to see a full curriculum yes
absolutely
absolutely further questions
representative Damon thank you thank you
for bringing this forward I'm I'm
thrilled to see it I do need some
clarification on the amendment okay
because the way I read it where line one
of the Amendments says replacing the
11th and 12th whereas Clauses so I
counted the
whereases and I got to lines 21 to 29
but I'm not sure that's what you
said so if you could just tell us what
part of the original draft is being
replaced by the amendment so we
understand it correctly okay um line one
of the amendment is is just an
explanation that shouldn't be in there
that's not text that belongs in the
actual
bill so
so the rest of the amendment in the
amendment lines three right to 10 where
where does that go in the bill yeah let
me um so line four is uh was
22 okay so from line 22 and then uh line
six was
24 and and line 24 yes so that the
wording on on that that second section
there that uh Roman numeral 2 um we we
just tightened up the wording thank you
for the clarification and then and then
of course the the uh resol down at the
bottom
okay further questions from the
committee uh representative have you
given any thought to you're talking
about compiling and
disseminating a curricula or curriculum
to the
schools developed by uh the two agencies
that you mentioned here yeah uh have you
given any thought to a fiscal note or to
the costs of doing this uh to
and and to disseminate a curriculum we
need the standards associated with
it um and of course and and curriculum
is a responsibility of the local school
district instruction and curriculum is a
local issue in the state so our concern
primarily is where's the the where all
come to put this all together and then
disseminate
it um initially we're looking at at sort
of an exploratory committee you know
from uh Dees and DHHS working with
stakeholders to sort of get this
information out and get it in some kind
of a form um you're right I mean you've
got to have standardizations for
curriculum so this is just the first
step that will lead eventually to some
kind of
dissemination and just as a point of
clarification has there do are there
ever fiscal notes associated with house
resolutions not with house
resolutions but in this case you're
going towards a development of a
curriculum which generally speaking
would be done through either well you
done through the Department of Education
uh with a task force of Educators to
come together it might involve technical
support from UNH or clean Keen or
Plymouth uh it may involve other
agencies and departments coming forward
um and organizations that are nonprofits
are that are familiar with the topic of
being discussed and working
collaboratively together to develop this
uh however eventually to be disseminated
has to be done through the department of
education so this house resolution
essentially gets the conversation
started M you know it's not a bill so
it's not a mandate we we can't we're not
making them set up a committee we're not
making them spend money we're suggesting
that they consider these these topics so
um it's it's a it's a a legislative
attempt to get the conversation
started and then and then once it's
started we can go from there and maybe
next term I'll have a bill on with a
fiscal
note further questions from the
committee representative cascaden uh
thank you Mr chair just a quick question
as I was thinking about this I think
this this would be fascinating but do
you know if there are any climate change
electives offered in high schools in New
Hampshire at this point or you know I am
not the person to answer that but you've
got a whole slew of people behind me
that have that
answer all right now I was just curious
because it would be in yeah yeah
one resource you might use is the
education Commission of the states they
they deal with curriculum they deal with
topics within the schools and there may
be another state that is gone further
than this right now you might be able to
borrow a little bit of that information
I'm sorry did you say Ed it's called ECS
education
commiss which we're members of and we we
research and do a lot of work through
them okay thank you I will look to
that further questions from the
committee oh thank you oh my pleasure
thank
you and i' like to invite uh Aubrey
Nelson
thank you welcome
um chairman lad and distinguished
members of the house and education
committee thank you for having me today
I'm testifying in support of house
resolution 30 urging a rob a robust
climate education in schools including
current environmental and economic
information um some of my written
testimony talks about some of the very
specific um experiences that I've had I
work for uh the New Hampshire and energy
education project um we actually do a
lot of the work um around climate and
energy education in the state um and we
feel that it's important um that this
resolution passed partially because we
just want to set a precedent and so that
school boards can look and say oh this
is recommended by the state the House of
Representatives thinks that this is a
great um thing to do in our school and
so school boards can look at that and
say oh okay that like that has a pretty
High endorsement from you all
um so in my work I have a great
opportunity to learn about energy and
climate with young people around the
state hear what they have to say one of
the pieces that keeps coming back to me
however is that as they learn one of the
fill-in-the blank pieces I think that
goes into a robust education is okay so
what do we do about it um and what I
hear from students and one of the most
important ways to to tackle Eco anxiety
or climate anxiety is the ability and
opportunity to take
action um when kids are just told about
something it feels overwhelming when any
of us are just told about some of these
things or if they're not told about
these things and just left to wonder so
I encounter students constantly who are
like well I know something's happening
the example I have in here is that a
student in Hinsdale was like well I know
what happening cuz I used to be able to
play in the snow Banks during my
kindergarten class and my little brother
doesn't have snow Banks they have mud
Banks my own son is in kindergarten and
I feel similarly like he comes home with
mud on his pants not wet
pants um so they know that it's
happening students know that it's
happening but we want to make sure that
every class has opportunity to think
about okay why is this happening and so
the Clause your 2 minutes is up okay I'm
sorry um I would just say also in
closing that we have um we have a lot of
resources to do this and I'm working
with the students at 350 to build a
robust uh opportunity of resources for
school districts if they want to refer
to that thank very much do you want to
take any questions yes thank you
represent McDonald thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I'm
looking at your rting testimony and you
note your experience um um creating
workshops are these in schools and are
they a part of a particular class that
we should be aware of yeah so we can
offer workshops Hands-On workshops to
teachers um around the state of New
Hampshire um many of them are free
thanks to our partnership with New
Hampshire saves so we can come and do
energy and climate education in schools
um and then we also have professional
development for teachers who are looking
to know how to do this with in a way
that's joyful not Doom and Gloom and
anxiety produ ing um and how to help
students take action so we have a whole
host of opportunities we also have
equipment that folks can borrow if they
want to do it themselves so an
curriculum that's free online that they
can use and if I may have a followup yes
are any of these classes for the
students perhaps they have a course in
the class relating to the environment
and you may come in to teach part of the
course for the students not the teachers
MH yep we can do that we do that a lot
actually with u career technology
students who want to learn learn about
green jobs we do that for um K through
12 classes it can be specific to
environment but it doesn't necess
necessarily have to be thank you
yeah represent whitcock thank you
chairman good afternoon thank you for
bringing your expertise to us uh the
question earlier was do you have any
idea about how many high schools
currently have either an environmental
uh act uh Club organization and or a
curriculum in their Science Program I'm
not sure how many specifically have a
club and because everything is like
based locally and what what is offered
sometimes those programs also come and
go so I grew up in mboro and we had one
for three years and then it disappeared
and then it came back I don't have a
specific number no um I know that it
often depends on interest Staffing um
and right now there's a lot of interest
we're seeing for sure amongst the
students um and I got involved with a
350 USB because students were coming to
us with this demand of we want more um
so I'm here today partially because they
want me to be okay thank you thank you
Mr chairman you're welcome are there
other questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
uh call
Sonia Whitaker
orski
y I'll tell you the students handwriting
here is much better than I've seen some
from some of the adults really they need
a little course in penmanship but you're
doing good job here keep it up okay um
hello my name is Sonia wosi and I'm a
nsha High School North senior I live at
23 B G Parkway in nsha I support hr30
because I believe that all students
deserve their resources and teaching to
be climate literate and to take
advantage of the opportunities that are
growing green economy offers last year
as a High School junior I had the
opportunity to take AP environmental
science I was lucky I realized that many
other students don't get this
information on climate that they are
missing out on a subject matter that
will impact them for the rest of their
lives they weren't given the knowledge
they needed to feel confident in a
changing world or to make a change in
their own communities and most
significantly they weren't given the
option to learn about a growing field of
green jobs or the importance of a stable
climate to New Hampshire's Agriculture
and
tourism what is absolutely insane to me
that we risk losing
7,485 jobs and over 65 million in state
and government revenue if we lose our
ski season to climate change and
according to the Department of energy in
2022 renewable energy jobs grew by
almost 4% Nationwide and now represent
over 40% of total energy jobs from solar
technicians to innov Innovative startups
workers to fill green jobs are in high
demand we all saw the shocking flooding
across the Sea Coast region this year as
we do deal with more intense weather
patterns we are also going to need more
workers to complete climate adaptation
projects such as maintaining dams and
restoring washed out roads by educating
students on climate we can show how
lucrative and vital these career paths
are and generate support for projects
that prioritize climate resilient
infrastructure a stronger emphasis on
climate will only make New Hampshire's
economy stronger I'm here to say that
every New Hampshire student needs and
deserves to learn about climate in
school and students as well as everyone
else who relies on New Hampshire's
economy are disadvantaged when we do not
recognize the critical value of climate
education I ask you will you do the
right thing for New Hampshire students
our future and our state's environment
and
economy um and I'm open to questions and
I'll try to answer as best I can thank
you very much are there any questions
from the
committee when you took your AP course
were you able able to get dual
concurrent enrollment with one of the
state universities at the same time I
was not
okay got to check that out
Dave any other
questions thank you very
much yeah yeah well nashille I thought
they have it live yes if all these
students have testimony may make it
easier because they're not leaving it
you they written they're all written
testimony yeah if you have written
testimony and you only have one copy if
you're willing to depart with that we
can put it into the clerk's record here
which it's important so if you have a
copy just drop it off with one of the
Reps straight off on the left hand your
right hand side here and we'll make sure
it gets as a part of the
record um okay the next one right here
is uh Elizabeth Bowski bosi B
okay hello honorable committee thank you
for having me today my name is Elizabeth
bosi and I live in Portsmith and I'm
here to testify in support of hr30 today
so some relevant background information
about me is that I have a M's in Social
Work concentrating in environmental and
energy Poli policy um but I came from a
teaching background I taught for middle
school and high school for six years
prior to getting my degree um and one of
the major reasons that I actually
switched my degree was because of how
often my students would Express um
frequent growing climate anxiety over
the years and I appreciated the question
that you asked about whether or not that
was coming from things like some of the
data that has not necessarily played out
or also some things like media headlines
but most of the things that my students
were saying was contributing to anxiety
were things that they could see and feel
some of the things I already mentioned
today like shorter Winters um but a lot
of my students came from farming
backgrounds and farming families and or
like the food business and a lot of them
are losing business over the year
because of lack of food supply because
of things that are contributing from
climate
change um so consequently I also noticed
a gap in our education system and being
able to give them the information about
why this is happening and also how we
can make it better we have the solutions
out there and education is a huge part
of that solution so this summer when
discussing with a 350 New Hampshire
action youth team about issues facing
their communities and lives one of the
central things that came up for students
was lack of access around climate
Science
Education um this was also reiterated by
parents and community members across a
number of forums that did occur so part
of the reason why we worked with many
youth on this house resolution was
because of right now how bare the
standards are of climate science um in
New Hampshire um there are only a few
standards total and they're mainly
addressing weather patterns which when
taught in isolation of some of these
wider topics that are introduced in this
house resolution um aren't as
contextualized so for example some of
the topics that we outlined in this
house resolution were agriculture
sustainability energy and jobs in
various environmental fields in this
sense one of the benefits of hr30 is the
outcome of Youth staying in New
Hampshire to do green jobs which
benefits New Hampshire's local economy
and also helps retain our youth
population in New Hampshire which is
something that we've seen as a growing
problem in the last few years your two
minutes are up all right thank you um
I'll just sing in conclusion that you
had asked about the finances of this
potential um resolution so it has been
introduced in a few States but most um
concentrated in New Jersey and it cost
there about $5 million in Grants um and
they're still ongoing some research
around that right now Connecticut is
also planning to adapt the same thing I
think that the number would be smaller
in New Hampshire because we have a
smaller population um but just wanted to
bring that number to the table too thank
you yeah any questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
uh Susan
Kaplan I'm going to go over there now
could I say about four minutes right
this good break good afternoon and thank
you to the education committee my name
is Sue Kaplan I live in Lebanon and I'm
here to support hr30 with thanks to
Representatives Thomas and
Kaplan with a c and a
k as well as the young people from 350
New Hampshire I'm the founder of a of
sustainable Futures Consulting I work
with businesses to uh incorporate
environmental strategies communicate
their social and environmental impact
and amplify their bottom
line my work and passion focuses on a
healthy climate through Technology
nature-based Solutions and
education I was a Pioneer in corporate
environmental and social responsibility
for Polaroid Corporation decades ago and
uh working on packaging batteries and
materials I worked on Energy Efficiency
programs energy storage and Community
sustainability in Massachusetts for 7
years and I taught in the sustainability
dual major at the University of New
Hampshire um in collaboration with Dr
Cameron Wake who is a leading climate
scientist students heard from speakers
in businesses municipalities nonprofits
and universities they are focusing in
this in their dual major on creating
Solutions job opportunities and a good
life I urge you to move the resolution
forward so that the young people in our
State know that adults are not okay when
sea level rises and Storm surges along
the Sea Coast Dev devastates roads homes
and livelihoods and we're not okay when
the flooding in manad County also
destroys
infrastructure why does
hr30 matter to New
Hampshire from my
perspective I want this new generation
to be able to ski enjoy winter sports
like we have I want students to be
trained for work in Energy Efficiency
solar energy electric vehicle charging
Forest restoration soil regeneration and
building affordable housing and don't we
all want young people to find joy in
exploring nature and the exciting
opportunities to impact our state
positively thank you your uh two minutes
up thank you um I hope that this
resolution will pass thank you for
listening to to my testimony thank you
uh yes
representative thank you real quick you
said you were the founder of an
organization in the beginning can you
repeat what that is uh it's a consulting
firm sustainable Futures
Consulting thank you thank you next is
uh Ray Lee
Hall or Kaye Hall
Maybe
hi thank you for having me my name is
Kaye Hall I live at 16 preserve Drive in
Nashville New Hampshire and I'm a
student I'm here today to express my
support of the bill hr30 as climate
education will eventually play an
important role in protecting New
Hampshire's infrastructure and Wildlife
due to the climate change already
prevailing today our state has already
has already seen four severe flooding
events in this past decade these
flooding events not only caus the state
millions of dollars to restore damaged
roads and roaded stream Banks but also
polluted a bunch of aquatic habitats New
Hampshire these severe storms have
allowed for more invasive species to
enter New Hampshire's ecosystem as well
what this climate change means for
wildlife is also that birds will have a
higher mortality rate and soil multiple
species of native fish plants will have
to adapt to changes in their water as
well which puts much stress on them and
increases the chance of them being
overtaken by invasive species this
information has been taken right from
New Hampshire's official facing fishing
game department right under this
information on the website there is a
list of many ways people can take action
to help with these severe storms in
Wildlife one of those ways is for people
to educate themselves on how climate
change will will affect their
environment
hr30 will only help promote this
protection for New Hampshire which is
why it is so important that is it is
used to help youth understand early on
about how to protect their
environment in communities I may only be
a student right now but I believe that
more people are aware of what's going on
in their environment they'll also feel
the need to protect it and take their
new knowledge with them later into their
lives hr30 will help introduce youth
topics about our climate and the history
behind it which again will help Prov
provide future paths should they also
choose to want to protect New
Hampshire's environment and stay in the
state hr30 is not only about
implementing more of a climate focused
education into our schools it's a way to
provide youth more perspective for the
community they live in I support hr30
because I love New Hampshire and I
believe this bill will benefit my
generation and the generations to come
thank you very much questions not seeing
any thank you very much for being here
today thank you so much
next is Eden
Goodman good afternoon committee my name
is Eden Goodman I live at sixe Meadow
Drive in nashu New Hampshire I
appreciate the opportunity I have to
speak in support of hr30 as a senior in
high school nearing the end of my public
schooling I've reflected on the
Environmental Education I've received
over the years being told to turn the
lights off when leaving a room and
recycle Beyond this I had the
understanding that environmental issues
could only be tackled by adults with
political power realizing that climate
change will affect my generation far
more than those currently in office all
I could do was hope that someway someday
someone in my generation would be able
to tackle these issues I was eventually
given an internship opportunity allowing
me to learn more about food systems and
agriculture I opened up to the idea of
sustainable agriculture and agricultural
impact on climate gaining an
understanding of how soil can sequester
carbon from the atmosphere and how food
Transportation contributes negatively to
climate changed my understanding of the
environmental issues we Face knowing the
vast contribution of AG that agriculture
can have in mitigating or exacerbating
the effects of climate change I see how
protecting our planet is not only about
conserving resources but also taking the
actions to look after the health of our
Earth these Concepts impacted many of my
habits and the decisions I make daily
when buying food and other things also
this is exactly why I support this
resolution expanding education on
environmental issues will enable
students to make eco-conscious decisions
and empower the students of today with
providing them the background necessary
to one day combat environmental issues
as the engineers scientists and
politicians that have the power and
means to do
so thank you any
questions see none thanks very much for
being
here uh next uh Sarah W
TR hello my name is Sarah W drob I'm a
senior at Nasha High School North and
I'm support of the HR uh the house
resolution 30 uh in my experience people
my age ignore the climate crisis or
maybe they will acknowledge that it
exists but they won't take any further
steps to try to help
when I've asked my peers and my
classmates about why they won't take any
further steps there's usually two
responses they don't know what to do or
they don't feel like anything that they
do do will be enough according to a
recent study reported in linet a
scientific journal 62% of Youth
experience climate anxiety and 67%
experience climate
fear as children our fears are often
regarded as irrational by adults for
example
being afraid of the dark or the monsters
under our bed however this fear is
rational and it's very
real a robust climate literacy
curriculum in New Hampshire schools
would instill hope in younger
Generations by providing knowledge
information and solutions that make the
climate crisis feel less
overwhelming it is a big issue but it's
an issue that we as students can help
fix if we're educated on it properly
starting at younger age the climate
crisis impacts everyone on this planet
if there's something for the Youth of
America to be educated on it's climate
change as residents of New Hampshire
even as young adults or children we have
seen the impacts that climate change has
had on our state whether it's hearing
our ski team friends complain about dry
season um and not being able to get on
the slopes or we see that our younger
brothers or sisters are not playing in
the snow doesn't matter we see the
effects we see the
impacts by educating us on it we can
help change the course for New Hampshire
as well as the world in the wise words
of Sir Francis Bacon knowledge is power
give us the power to help mitigate
climate change restore hope in my
generation that our environment is not a
lost cause and there is still time to
make a difference we need a
comprehensive climate curriculum within
our schools thank you very much
yes represent thank you representative
and thank you for testifying and I'd
have to agree with you that students
should be involved and I always like
when students come to testify my
question being the bill is not only
urging a robust climate education in
schools but it also wants to include
current environmental and economic
information being a student how would
you
say the curriculum should discern maybe
conflicting opinions since there are
disagreements revolving this issue how
should all sides be discussed okay so I
am a firm believer that climate change
does exist and I believe that when you
look at scientific facts those can be
presented in with data um I believe
however that there are opinions that are
differing um I think as long as teachers
and our Educators stick to facts that
are presented within the curriculum that
it should be okay um I also think with
like other topics that we discuss in
schools that may be controversial
uh our educators are generally trained
uh in making sure that all people feel
safe in the classroom
environment thank you very much for
being
here um oik from Londoner and uh maybe
you can help me with the last
name hi hi um my name is oi chakra it's
a it's a pretty long last name so I
don't really mind yeah so hello
committee hello committee members my
name is oi chakra and I a junior who
attends the academy for Science and
design in nashille New Hampshire though
I attend school in Nashua I reside in
londonairy
I support the hr30 resolution as it will
benefit the entirety of uh the entirety
of New Hampshire and future generations
to come
the importance of climate change needs
to be addressed especially in younger
Generations as we are the future of this
nation there is no better way than
implementing this than a climate
literacy education program within the
New Hampshire school system and
educating the Youth of New Hampshire by
motivating them to participate in
climate related events Gatherings like
litter cleanups in public parks preserve
the environment and keep humans and
animals from hazardous
conditions events like these can
encourage participation from everyone
interested and will influence more and
more events like this with climate
education implementation in the schools
the youth will also learn how efforts
like pollution deterent events are
essential to keep
Society to society to keep New Hampshire
parks and regions thriving Greener
sustaining our air breathable and our
waterers flowing therefore I support the
hr30 resolution as it will provide a
system to to influence the Youth of New
Hampshire to have a clear uh and concise
knowledge about climate related topics
and influence our society to participate
in more cleanup events that will keep
our state pollutant free thank you so
much for your
time thank you um any questions yes
represent Cornell thank you and thank
you for taking my question I know AP
environmental Sciences offered in
Nashville high school and I know it's
offered in the Manchester schools do you
have more environmental science is at I
know your science is your school um do
you have more classes on this then
offered in the other schools yeah so uh
I attend the academy for Science and
design it's a public charter school in
nashwa and it's um it has other
environmental science courses like um uh
honors environmental science you have to
take that as a required course in ninth
grade um for a graduation requirement
and there you just you learn about uh
environmental science and yes there is
AP environmental science offered at my
school
yeah thank you yes R Bayon thank you I
just want to follow up on your answer to
that question have you noted a
difference in your environmental
knowledge having that AP class as a
freshman compared to your peers who
clearly are very interested in this
topic but perhaps didn't have access to
that coursework so so soon if at all
yeah um so in my environmental science
class uh it we did learn a lot about uh
climate education because my school is
also um like influences this among their
students as well um and yes we learned a
lot more uh like I would say it really
did help me uh learn more um and if
students that didn't take this course uh
if I didn't take this course I wouldn't
have as much knowledge as had today um
on specific topics related to that so
yes it does help thank you thank you
very much thank you uh Taylor
Barry
good afternoon my name is Taylor Barry
and I'm a senior at Nash High School
North I'm here today to testify in favor
of
hr30 the climate crisis is no longer
some distant threat in the future it's
here that's scary especially for today's
youth this fear and anxiety stretches
into every aspect of Our Lives it's hard
to focus on building a a success future
when we know that it will be threatened
by climate change that's why we're here
today as the next generation of
scientists leaders and businessmen and
women we are demanding that action be
taken to save our planet and save our
futures one of the most impactful
climate change mitigation strategies is
education a successful climate literacy
curriculum is comprehensive it details
not only the scientific aspects of
climate change but the socioeconomic
ones as well this builds urgency among
students the curriculum then converts
this urgency into action by teaching
students how to make eco-conscious
decisions a 2017 study found that
students at San Jose University were
able to lower their Global carbon
footprint by 2.86 tons per year after
taking a global climate change course if
each new hes 170,000 students in public
schools were able to do this then
hundreds of thousands of tons of carbon
dioxide would be prevented from entering
the atmosphere each year in addition to
inspiring students to take action
climate change curriculum details
positive developments in the
environmental field as a result hope is
spread among students which combats fear
and
anxiety according to a bipartisan um
2023 Yale study 75% of people across New
Hampshire and Across the Nation agree
with this statement that global warming
should be taught in schools we did too
as students Educators and activists we
are demanding that action be taken to
mitigate the climate crisis there is no
better time to take that action than now
thank you and I am open in questions
thank you very
much represent Damon thank you could you
just please repeat the statistic you
just gave us about the number of tons
per year decrease in I think it was
carbon impact so at San Jose University
after taking a year-long global climate
change course students were able to
lower their foot uh their carbon
footprint by 2.86 tons of carbon dioxide
per
year thank you very much for being
here uh Philip
Brown are there any other students that
need to speak are we going to have
enough time for everyone yeah
yes my name is Philip Brown I'm a
retired High science teacher you gota
wait till he gets oh I do I can't I
can't use my teacher voice
okay oh my recording voice okay so
anyway I'm a retired coner High science
teacher of 35 years uh I'm also a
co-director of an organ ganization
called SOS steam we could say it's uh
save our students Save Our State save
our species right and it's done through
the use of steam education everybody
knows what stem is science technology
engineering and math we feel that we
have to add the Arts so that students
can interpret and share what they've
learned through the visual uh uh written
and Performing Arts and steam is
a is an authentic Science assessment we
are looking for ways to do this right
things that we can do as a as a society
to help our students get rid of this
anxiety help our students uh develop
skills that will allow them to survive
into the future uh the backside of that
sheet that I handed out to you has some
recommendations on what we should be
doing we've already focused on energy
Alternatives we've already focused on uh
civil engineering and architectural
designs that need to be changed I would
also like to suggest that we develop a
spiraling K to2 science curriculum that
uses authentic Science assessment uh in
the manner of the forest Watch program
that I was part of at the University of
New Hampshire for almost 25 years so
there is a way to do it but the the key
right now things that I think we should
be working on with our students are
forestry Forest management tree growth
tree monitoring and garden growing okay
because food security is going to become
ever more important and we get our
students out and get their hands in the
soil we give them active hope for a
future so how do we pay for it someone
asked that question a while ago I'm a
baby boomer right I'm I'm primarily
responsible along with other baby
Boomers for the plate that these
students are are faced with Baby Boomers
control $75 trillion in wealth I won't
use the normal t-w the t-w that I
suggest is that baby boomers
tithe that we contribute 10 2 to 10% of
our uh pensions and annual income or our
wealth to doing things to help support
our children
at the same time meline back in the
60s and the 70s developed an
organization called the gray
Panthers
volunteers retired people who were
willing to Champion and support our
students into the future sorry your time
is up I am done great good timing thank
you very much for being here any
questions um you can you can check out
the website bar Christina I have other
copies over here on the table
is uh Barrett here guess not thank you
um
Nathan Kelly
ha good afternoon chairman well chairman
lad's not here but uh members of the
Comm committee um my name is uh Matthew
cathaline and uh I'm a resident of
conquer I'm here representing myself
today just a concerned citizen with a
background in this um I worked with a
New Hampshire DHHS um as a manager of
the prior climate and health program
that operated from 2013 to 2022
currently a private consultant um a
trainer and also University um
instructor uh today I'd like to talk
about environmental health aspects of
the proposed uh curriculum specifically
environmental progress you should be
teaching is in current in the current
form I'm neutral on the bill I think
there could be some improvements
made um the good news is that on a
national and state level most of the
citizens um have adapted well to our
change in climate and his extremes and
heat and precipitation um even as the
climate warms our nation's been able to
reduce heat related deaths significantly
by over over the last 50 years cutting
the risk of death in half in our cities
in addition there's been improvements in
air quality um and we've reduced
premature deaths by over 100,000 per
year um and we've reduced greenhouse gas
emissions by only 30% these are
environmental health and improvements
that you rarely hear about from media
and advocacy groups My Hope Is that bill
will encourage an informed conversation
within the legislative body in our
schools we should teach our young people
that this is a strong and healthy Nation
um and when needed we have taken bold
actions to improve the environment um
and public health for all of our
citizens um through bar partisan action
I believe we need to teach um our
citizens and youth about um our past
successes if they're going to have the
competency and the critical skill um uh
critical thinking needed to take on the
challenges in the future I want to say
we have solved big problems before and
we will again I think that's a big
message that's not getting through to
our schools um um bad news is the
climate is rapidly warming it's causing
disruption in our weather patterns
unbalanced ecosystems and threatening
our health here in New Hampshire my work
with the Department of Health really
discovered that probably the strongest
climate signal is on tick B expansion of
tick habitat and tick born disease
that's really significant that's strong
you can see it other things less certain
but we know the number of days over 90
um heat and temperature are increasing
and number of extreme weather events are
increasing um time's up to times up all
right I'll just say that um I believe
that there's an opportunity to improve
our science curcum by including more
information on on environmental progress
and success but a few questions remain
what is the content of the current
climate curriculum in our schools is it
adequate or is it robust and if climate
current if the curriculum is changed
we're examples of the best curriculum I
think that if you looked into those in
the near future that'd be very useful
use um for this particular resolution
happy to take any questions thank you
very
much uh thank you for being here
today uh
an Paul
lney if I'm
close yes you hit it you hit the nail on
the head and pod lipney I'm from Chester
I'm going to um cut my remarks in half
and and really make make it very short
because so much has been said and it's
all great
information
um hr30 introduces climate education in
the High School curriculum as a former
educator I have great respect for
Curious students who seek to enrich
their learning by incorporating
challenging subjects into their work
what knowledge at this crucial time 50
Years After Earth Day could be more
important than understanding the root
causes of climate change and its impact
on a world these very students will
inherit I'm a longtime resident of
Chester five years ago I proposed a
warrant article resolution in support of
honoring indigenous people's day the
town approved it persuaded I Believe by
the testimony of one high school student
who stepped up to the podium asking that
students like himself be taught all
facts regarding the history of Columbus
ignorance is not Bliss he argued just
the opposite being underinformative
CL as students face an increasingly
unpredictable environmental future the
more science-based data they receive the
better informed they become and less
likely to experience feelings of
helplessness and despair instead they're
more likely to adopt The Credo don't
throw up your hands roll up your sleeves
I've witnessed impressive results when
students develop useful resources for
engagement their knowledge builds
effective communication skills as you
seen and
self-confidence the lived experiences
students share with each other whether
they be extreme weather events or an in
environmental justice concerns in their
communities they are creating an active
Youth Corps together you see firstand
how students mature when they share
information they write for newspapers
speak with local Civics groups and state
legislators write petitions and request
interviews clearly you elected officials
value students who Advocate passionately
for environmental causes such as plastic
reduction in stool cafeterias composting
of dining hall waste Beach cleanups
water monitoring and testing or rallying
to protect New Hampshire's natural
resources thank you that's the two
minutes thank you very much sure no
questions or questions see none thank
you very much for being here appreciate
it and uh wrapping up will be uh Kim
Barry hi good
afternoon thank you for taking me as the
last um
speaker my name is Kim Barry I grew up
in New Hampshire I'm a UNH graduate and
currently live in Nashville New
Hampshire I'm here today as a mother of
school aged children in the public
school system and as a registered nurse
for over 25 years I fully support
resolution HR 30 to provide education in
schools related to climate change within
a comprehensive curriculum children need
to understand what is causing climate
change and its impact impact on science
their health their environment and the
overall economy of New Hampshire just
Monday Time Magazine published an
article entitled The Hidden health care
costs of climate change the article
reviewed that since 24 million people
worldwide have died due to floods
wildfires heat waves droughts and Other
Extreme weather events directly
correlated with warming temperatures
these events increase emergency care and
require significant clinical and
financial resources for months even
years after the event we have the
opportunity to proactively address them
and create Future Leaders to prevent
these costly
emergencies here in New Hampshire we are
at extreme risk for large wildfires just
like the western parts of the US in 2018
and 20 20 fires have destroyed over 2.77
million hectares of forest changing rain
patterns increasing wind speeds and
increasing Heat have reduced overall
rainfall in the Summers leaving the
forest drier than previous Seasons a
wildfire in the White Mountains would be
devastating to our precious State a
wildfire would be deadly and cause
significant smoke pollution asthma
reactions respiratory failure and
cardiovascular fa failure and other
health concerns for Granite State
communities in addition to costing the
state significant funding to control the
fires and rebuild communities we must
protect our state and Implement counter
measures to reduce our vulnerability to
wilda wildfires and other climate change
disasters by educating our youth we are
providing a pathway for them to create
systems products and various protections
to save our forest and preserve our
health by reducing greenhouse gases we
reduce the incidence of wildfires by
reducing wildfires we preserve our pure
air quality by protecting protecting our
air quality we reduced asthma and
respiratory complications it is all
connected education leads to change
which improves our state and the health
of granite Staters thank you thank you
very much uh good wrap up um any
questions see none I want to thank
everybody for being here especially the
students um and um we have a busy day
scheduled tomorrow I think we begin at
uh
9:30
yes so I'm sorry just just two very
short things um like everybody on this
committee I I'm willing to bet I am so
impressed with our New Hampshire youth
um our future is in really good hands um
I also know that you're executing this
tomorrow and I am subbing in another
committee so I won't be here so if you
have any questions please send them to
me by email thank you
um so 9:30 tomorrow Republicans will CAU
us here at 9:00 a.m. and um we all might
have a little uh caucus uh uh once once
we get started uh tomorrow um but um
looks like a busy day ahead so thank you
very
much
know